It was November 3rd
, 1991 and Blake Newsom loved his job.
He had a passion for organization,
an undying love of American political history,
and was a life-long member of the Republican
party. That’s why he took great pride in his
position as a filing clerk at the Ronald Reagan
Presidential Library. Or at least, he did,
until his horrifying encounter with SCP – 1981.
The worst day of Blake’s life began like any
other. He was taking inventory of the archive’s
wide array of Betamax tapes, and
making sure they were all arranged
carefully and conformed
with the filing system.
One by one, he checked footage of speeches and
addresses off of his list, until he came upon a
strange tape that had no business being there.
The tape looked to be completely normal, but it
hadn’t been recorded on the archive inventory.
And there was something else off about it. A
single white sticker was on the front of
the tape with “RONALD REGAN CUT UP WHILE
TALKING" scrawled hastily with what was
probably a felt-tipped marker. Blake was shocked
and appalled – they hadn’t even
spelled the President’s name correctly!
What poor Mr. Newsom didn’t know was that he
was about to see something so disturbing that
he’d look back on that misspelling like
it was a treasured childhood memory.
Standard policy for tapes like this would be to
review and catalogue, or even throw it out if
necessary. Typically, a lowly filing clerk
like Blake would need to seek approval from his
superiors, but curiosity got the better of him.
He commandeered one of the library’s televisions
and Betamax cassette players, and started
watching the footage. For the first minute or so
nothing seemed out of the ordinary, just the
president standing at a podium giving his iconic
“Evil Empire” speech to the National Association
of Evangelicals at Sheraton Twin Towers
Hotel, Orlando, Florida, on March 8th, 1983.
However, the second the tape hit the one minute
and ten seconds mark, something unnatural
began to occur. President Reagan’s speech began
to veer off, as the topic of conversation shifted
from the importance of family values to the
exquisite taste of human flesh. Blake was taken
aback. Surely, he was hearing things? But the
tape only got worse. President Reagan began to
divulge the fact that he enjoyed
the taste of young flesh the best,
particularly that of infants. As
Reagan began to go into detail about how exactly
one should best cook an infant if you want to
seal in the flavour, the crowd erupted
into modest applause.
Blake started to feel
sick. He’d remembered watching this
speech, and President Reagan had said
nothing of the sort! Things only got weirder as
the President’s cheek suddenly opened up into a
long, bleeding gash, as though someone had cut
into his face with an invisible knife. As the
speech continued, and Reagan’s words became more
nonsensical and incoherent, the injuries got
worse, too. His face developed puncture wounds,
like he was being stabbed. Skin in some areas
rotted and peeled off. Reagan showed no awareness
of the horrifying injuries that seemed to be
occurring spontaneously on his
body. This was a living nightmare!
The tape came to a merciful end 22 minutes in,
after President Reagan’s throat appeared to be
slashed open and his insane speech was reduced to
quiet gurgles. It fizzled out into static shortly
after, and Blake politely retired to the
bathroom to throw up. Was this some sick prank or
tampering or camera trickery, perhaps? He
didn’t know but that tape was disgusting, and
whoever was responsible had to be punished.
Newsom contacted the police, hoping obscenity
charges could be pressed against the creator
of the tape once they were found. The tape was
taken into evidence, and a low-level police
investigation into the possible culprits began.
While the police officers who viewed the tape
reported nightmares in the weeks following, the
creator of the tape was never found. The
investigation truly came to an end when a superior
closed the case and the tape disappeared from
the evidence locker. This, as you probably could
have guessed, was the work of a field agent
from The SCP Foundation. Amnestics were then
used to erase the memories of everyone unlucky
enough to witness the tape, including Blake
Newsom, who could finally rest
easy and return to his filing work.
The anomalous tape was now in responsible hands.
It was given the designation SCP – 1981, and
given the object class “Safe” due to its easily
controlled and self-contained nature. Proper
research and testing was now able to begin and
while nothing about the construction of the tape
suggested anything inherently anomalous, repeat
viewings of the video made it clear that this
went far beyond mere doctored
footage of a Presidential speech.
Every single time the tape is played, both the
speech made and the injuries received by President
Reagan change. The few rules the tape seems to
always follow are that Reagan never reacts to
the injuries he’s receiving, it
always has the same beginning and
total runtime, and the speech is
always corrupted. These speeches
have been described as “mostly
incoherent, lacking any sort of
underlying thematic structure and largely
being composed of nonsensical anecdotes and
parables”, so not that dissimilar from a regular
Reagan speech, but the topics always turn
incredibly dark and have included torture,
mutilation, death, cannibalism, ritual sacrifice,
genocide, and more.
The range of injuries shown on President
Reagan in the videos have included, but are by no
means limited to, impalement, mutilation, flaying,
and some tortures so gruesome that the details
have been redacted from official files.
On several occasions, the details of President
Reagan’s speech have also eerily predicted the
future. These include successfully
predicting the September 11th
attacks in 2001 and the outcome
of the 2008 Russian presidential
election. Incidentally, this
isn’t even the only Reagan-related
SCP to predict the future. No,
there’s another entry in this
incredibly specific niche: SCP – 095, a
highly degraded copy of a comic known as
“The Atomic Adventures of Ronnie Ray-Gun.” The
title character bears a striking resemblance
to President Reagan, despite
the fact that the comic is
confirmed by Foundation tests to
have been written in the early 1930s.
The comic is set in the far-off
future world of the 1980s,
and follows a number of Ronnie’s
exploits in three stories.
The first, titled “Ronnie vs. Space
Admiral Carter”, seems to perfectly
describe the events of the
1980 presidential election.
The second, “Space Assassin!”, mirrors the
attempted assassination of President Reagan by
John Hinckley Jr. And the third, titled “Jungle
Planet!”, retells the Iran-Contra controversies
of 1986. These comics were produced under the
mysterious and apparently non-existent company,
“Future Funnies.” The Foundation hopes to
track down the other comics from this company
whenever possible, but they’ve had no luck on
that front. For now, there’s only SCP – 1981.
During initial testing,
Foundation staff watched the
tape frequently in case this strange, corrupted
version of President Reagan had any other valuable
predictions for the future. However, during
one of these screenings, one of the D-Class
observation personnel pointed and yelled at the
screen in horror.
Upon further examination of recorded footage,
researchers could see exactly what had concerned
the D-Class observer so much. While, in other
viewings of the tape, President Reagan’s press
detail had appeared totally normal, in this one
something was clearly amiss. Standing among the
other dull, suit-wearing
political aides was a tall
figure dressed in a midnight-black cloak with a
large, conical hood obscuring his face. The figure
didn’t appear to move in the footage – it just
stood there, menacingly. A later survey indicated
that this figure would appear in roughly one in
seven viewings of the tape.
This cloaked figure was designated SCP – 1981 –
1, and he became part of the recurring imagery
in the nightmares that often followed a viewing
of SCP – 1981. Naturally, despite containment
and preservation attempts, the Foundation was
aware that just like any normal tape, natural
magnetic interference would eventually degrade
it beyond use. Attempts to copy the footage onto
another Betamax tape failed to reproduce the
anomalous effects. That’s why the Foundation has
painstakingly recorded any video and audio
they could via a standard commercial camcorder.
In one particularly terrifying playback, SCP –
1981 – 1 took the president’s place at the podium,
staring directly into the camera. The words “I
SEE YOU” appeared over a black screen shortly
after. Staff members were ordered never to make
an attempt at communicating with the figure,
and instead contact a Level 4 superior if
such an event occurs during a playback again.
The frightening and unfortunate effects of SCP
– 1981 would come to their logical conclusion
under the watchful eye of Dr. James Kyle
Robinson, Managing Archivist of Inert Safe-Class
Objects and Anomalous Items at Site 73. He was
contacted by Special Agent Arnold Rodriguez
and Special Agent Ethan Tate, members of
secret service with a duty of care to President
Reagan. Word had gotten to Reagan that there was
an anomalous artefact in the possession of the
Foundation that directly pertained
to him, and he wanted to see it.
Dr. Robinson obtained files and transcripts
pertaining to SCP – 1981 and handed them over to
the Agents, but refused to allow President
Reagan to see the tape directly without
approval from
O5 Command.
But Reagan and the agents were persistent.
Eventually, O5 Command ordered a private
screening of the tape for President Reagan at
the Sanford Chemical Processing Plant – a front
business owned and operated by the Foundation
for Amnestic production. Dr. Robinson offered
President Reagan the use of Amnestics after
the session completed, but Reagan declined. The
screening took place in Conference Room B, and
the tape was re-played three times. It was on
the third playback that things
took an interesting turn.
As the mutilated Reagan on the screen began to
rant about drinking the blood of a child from the
skull of Vladimir Putin, Reagan began to
silently mouth along to the words, as though he
remembered them. He spoke about beings known
as “The Destroyers”, and potential apocalyptic
events to come. After the screening, Reagan
once again refused the offer of Amnestics, and
departed. It seemed as though all was well,
until a violent break-in at the Sanford Chemical
Processing Plant that left the night guard dead.
A large number of Amnestics had been stolen
during the break-in, and security footage
showed that Agents Tate and Rodriguez had been
responsible.
The two agents were tracked down and traced
to the residence of Ronald Reagan, where the
Foundation came upon a disturbing sight:
The agents had pillaged large
quantities of Class A and
B Amnestics and supplied them to President
Reagan, who – at some point after observing SCP –
1981 – had been driven into a dangerous madness.
The two agents wanted to cure him before he
caused harm to himself or others, but their
bungling had come with severe consequences.
Misapplying such a high quantity of Amnestics
had essentially destroyed Reagan’s mind, and
while the Foundation was able to stabilize his
condition, his impaired memory and cognitive
function would leave him unable
to care for himself independently.
In order to cover up for this grievous mistake,
a cover story was concocted about Reagan falling
victim to Alzheimer’s and facing severe cognitive
decline as a result. Both Agents Tate and
Rodriguez were fired for their actions, had
their memories wiped by the Foundation, and were
assigned new identities. Dr. Robinson,
for his part in the disaster,
had to face a Foundation Ethics
Committee Disciplinary Hearing.
While SCP – 1981 continues to
be classified as“Safe” due to
its unlikeliness to ever breach containment, when
you consider the havoc it wrought on the mind
of its singular target, “safe” is hardly the
word that comes to mind. It’s enough to make you
wonder what other tapes are lurking
out there, just waiting to be found...
“Every time a bell rings, an angel gets its
wings.” It’s an iconic line from “It’s a Wonderful
Life” and even if you don’t believe in angels,
it’s a pleasant image. After all, angels are
the embodiment of goodness and light, so an angel
getting its wings has to be a good thing, right?
Well, as anyone who’s ever eaten one
too many Christmas cookies can tell you,
it’s possible to have too much of a good
thing. Even something that sounds like
the embodiment of all things good, in theory,
can become deadly when taken to the extreme.
That is where SCP-469, also
known as the Many-Winged Angel,
comes in. This angel-like creature is
anything but innocent and in fact it has
been responsible for multiple deaths of SCP
Foundation personnel during its captivity.
SCP-469 may be deadly, but it is also
undeniably beautiful in a mysterious,
ethereal way. When first seen,
it appears to be nothing more
than a massive pile of pristine white
feathers, like something out of a pillow
commercial. The pile measures 24 feet in
diameter and weighs at least two tons.
However, like many of the entities
contained within the walls of the
Foundation’s countless containment
sites, all is not as it seems with 469.
What looks at first glance to be a
pile of feathers is in fact a dense,
curled mass of giant wings. The wings
vary in size, from the tiny wingspan of
a sparrow to the staggering 3.6-meter
wingspan of the wandering albatross.
The one thing they have in
common is their plumage,
with each wing being covered with
the same glossy white feathers.
The Foundation was able to perform a series of
X-rays on the mass of wings, revealing a skeletal
structure beneath the feathers. Like those of
a bird, the wings’ bones are hollow. However,
they are unnaturally soft and flexible, allowing
for a range of motion that no known birds possess.
This accounts for the curvature of the wings, and
their ability to coil tightly into each other.
The X-Ray also provided the first, and
only recorded glimpse at the creature
hiding underneath all of the feathers. At the
center of the layers upon layers of wings,
is a humanoid creature, curled into a fetal
position. In defiance of the laws of natural
anatomy, every single wing appears to be fused
to this creature’s spine. How it would be able
to move under the weight of these wings,
or if it even could, is as of yet unknown.
The first Foundation personnel lost
to SCP-469 were D-class personnel,
D-112 and D-624, who were sent
in to investigate the nature of
the creature and attempt to contact the
humanoid entity identified on the X-rays.
112 and 624 entered the room, equipped with gloves
and protective eye gear, as scientists watched the
situation unfold on a monitor on a video feed. No
one expected much to come of the encounter, the
working hypothesis was that the layers of feathers
would simply be too thick to get through without
seriously damaging the bones. It would be a
fairly uneventful experiment, or so they thought.
112 approached SCP-469 first, and attempted
to part a section of its feathers with his
hands as 624 stood back and observed. The
moment his fingertips touched the feathers,
a rustling sound filled the room.
The feathers began to quiver,
shaking as if all waking up
at once from a deep slumber.
Suddenly, in the blink of an eye, the hundreds
and hundreds of wings unfurled and pulled 112
into their depths. He was swept into a
swirl of feathers and, within seconds,
he had disappeared from view completely.
Though 624 and the scientists watching on
their monitor could no longer see him…they
could certainly hear him. From the moment the
wings pulled him into the sea of feathers,
112 had begun to scream in
agony. His screams persisted,
growing louder and more desperate even
as his voice cracked and grew weak.
624 stood, frozen in place with fear and shock.
624 was ordered to attempt to retrieve 112 from
the feathers, but made no move to do so. He simply
stared at the feathers, eyes wide, face pale,
as the pained shrieks of his colleague bounced off
the sterile white walls of the containment room.
A guard called over the intercom, threatening
to terminate 624 if he did not attempt to remove
112 from SCP-469’s grasp. This warning
seemed to shock 624 back into action,
and he made a run for the center feathers,
arms up to protect his face. Again, the sound
of rustling as the feathers began to quake. The
wings unfurled once more, and 624 did not even
have a chance to turn back before he was pulled in
to meet the same dismal fate as the other D Class.
His screams of pain joined 112’s
as the scientists watching over
the monitor could do nothing to help them.
As the two men cried out in pain and
horror from within their winged prison,
something began to happen that the scientists
had never seen before. The feathers started
to shake again, faster than before,
and at first the wings appeared to
be unfolding again. Upon a second look
though, it was clear they hadn’t moved.
There were simply more of them now. As the men
continued to scream, more feathers appeared,
the wings stretching out and elongating,
and new wings sprouting as if from nowhere.
SCP-469 appeared to be feeding
on the sound of the screams,
and using that energy to expand. It was only
after several long minutes when the screaming
finally stopped that the growth of the wings
did too. At this point, the wings shifted again,
expelling the bodies of 112 and 624 from within
its folds, dropping them limply on the ground.
Though their deaths were unfortunate, the loss of
112 and 624 did reveal some new information
about SCP-469. First, that it could grow,
and apparently needed to feed on sounds in order
to do so. Second, that it was deadly to humans,
and most likely to other living things as
well. Autopsies of 112 and 624’s corpses
would later reveal exactly what happened
to them, and how SCP-469 kills its prey.
Though 469’s feathers may look as
though they would be soft to the touch,
each feather is actually made up of sharp barbs
that are capable of piercing clothing and skin.
These barbs release a neurotoxin into the
system that activates every pain receptor
in the body of the victim. The neurotoxin
present in these feathers has not been
identified anywhere else in nature, but is
somewhat similar in structure and function
to the neurotoxins excreted by the cone snail
and in the bite of the blue-ringed octopus.
In addition to the pain-inducing neurotoxin, the
feathers also carry several unidentified stimulant
compounds, which seem to be intended to keep the
victim awake for as long as possible. Where the
neurotoxin on its own would induce enough
pain for the affected party to pass out
almost immediately, the stimulants
serve to keep the victim conscious.
SCP Foundation scientists posit that this
is so that 469 can get as much noise,
in this case in the form of screams,
out of its prey as possible and achieve
maximum growth before the captive
creature dies or goes into shock.
Further experiments confirmed this theory,
and showed that SCP 469 will react similarly
when exposed to any living creature capable of
making a sound and experiencing pain, not just
humans. Nonliving matter though, including
dead animals, elicit no response from 469.
Additional experiments were then undertaken
that involved applying various different
sounds in order to test their effect on
SCP 469’s growth. Though it feeds on any
sounds produced in its presence, it seems
to respond most strongly to musical sounds,
exhibiting a particularly strong response
to classical music. No sound elicits
a stronger reaction from this creature,
however, than the sound of ringing bells.
It is rumored that when a bell was
rung in the presence of the 469,
the humanoid at the center of the feathers
is said to have moved for the first time on
record. Apparently whatever is at the center
appeared to “wake up” and unfurl its wings,
revealing itself. But unfortunately, all
security footage of this incident has been wiped,
and the data has been expunged from the record
leaving the creature’s true form a mystery.
You may be remembering that four members of
Foundation personnel on record were lost to
SCP-469, and that only two have been mentioned
so far. The second pair of casualties resulted
when the Foundation attempted to terminate
SCP 469. Believing that there was no more
scientific benefit to keeping it alive,
or at least that the possible benefits
did not outweigh the risks, it was ordered that
SCP-469 be terminated by any means necessary.
Two skilled personnel, Dr. Jones and Dr.
Smith, were sent into the containment
facility in hazmat gear, armed with several
sharp instruments. They were to attempt to use
these to cut through the forest of feathers
and soft bones until they could reach the
humanoid at the center. It was presumed that
once they did and the creature no longer had
the protection of its poisonous feathers,
that it would be relatively easy to kill.
They could not have been more wrong.
Dr. Jones approached the dense cover of feathers
with a pair of sharpened gardening shears,
while Dr. Smith opted for a machete. At first,
the strategy appeared to be working. Dr. Jones
made several quick cuts, with feathers fluttering
to the floor and sticking to the Hazmat suit as
Dr. Smith slashed into the feathers with his
machete, making similarly promising progress.
However, the situation quickly took a turn
for the worse when Dr. Jones dropped her
shears and let out a bloodcurdling scream.
The feathers had taken a little longer to
through the suit to her skin, but somehow
they had managed to find a way just the
same. Smith grabbed Jones and attempted to
make a break for it, but he was too slow,
and far too close to the feathers already.
The wings wrapped around them and swallowed
them both up, leaving the researchers outside
helpless to do anything but listen to their
screams and wait for them to go quiet.
After several minutes they finally did,
and the now larger SCP-469 had officially
claimed another two Foundation personnel.
Obviously, 469 could not be terminated using any
methods that would place the responsible personnel
within its grasp. That was simply too risky.
So, the Foundation selected a team of D-class
personnel to attempt to burn the feathers with
an array of flamethrowers. Though the feathers
were vulnerable to fire and began to blacken
and disintegrate on contact, the sound of the
flames being expelled was loud enough to feed
SCP 469. Its growth was so quick in response to
the noise that the fire could not keep up with the
amount of new feathers and wings being produced.
By the time the flamethrowers ran
out of propellant, 469 was the same
size as it had been when they started. Other
termination methods have been discussed,
including the possibility of submerging the
entire creature in a highly corrosive acid,
but so far this has not yet been attempted.
Whatever they end up trying, it is clear
that nothing that produces a significant
amount of noise will be able to kill 469.
So, where is it now? What’s become of this
perverse angel with the never-ending wings?
Currently, it is kept isolated in an airtight,
soundproof chamber where nothing can trigger
the growth of any more wings. So, what
is it? An angel? A demon? A twisted,
mutated bird of some kind? It is entirely
possible we will never know. But It’s a
Wonderful Life had something right, even
if by accident. Every time a bell rings,
something, twisted and deadly
though it may be, gets its wings.
It was July of 2004, and Bill Murray was enjoying
the peak of an extremely successful career.
Not only had the iconic actor starred in some of
the most beloved comedies of the 20th Century,
including Ghostbusters and Groundhog Day, he’d
voiced the main character of the recently-released
live action Garfield movie. It’d been a financial
success, but it was a critical flop. Not that
this bothered Bill – he was happy with the
performance... and the paycheck. What he wouldn’t
be quite as happy about was the horrifying
encounter he was about to have with SCP – 3166.
On July 8th, Bill was enjoying a cold drink on
the porch of his luxurious Beverly Hills home.
The sky was beginning to darken as the sun set
in the west. It was a blissful evening. His wife,
Jennifer, was inside, watching TV. Nothing seemed
particularly out of the ordinary…Until he noticed
a quick flash of orange in the distance. It
was almost too fast to register, this large,
orange shape darting past the corner of his
eye. For a second, he entertained the thought
that it might have been an escaped tiger,
but it was gone too fast to really tell.
Bill finished his drink and headed
inside. He’d had enough for one night.
The next morning, he got up to read the paper, and
found the Garfield movie getting slaughtered by
the critics. One review stated “no one can accuse
Garfield: The Movie of infidelity to its source:
It faithfully conveys the banality of Jim
Davis's cartoon” Another called it“a film
without energy and without spirit.” He put the
paper down and ate his breakfast. A few blows
to the ego were worth it for the paydays
that came with big budget family films.
Just then his wife came to him with a strange
question: Were you walking around downstairs in
the middle of the night? No, he hadn’t, he’d
been sleeping like a baby. Why did she ask?
“Well…” Jennifer said. “I heard
some rustling downstairs last
night. It sounded like something big.”
He hadn’t heard anything though and told
her it was probably just her imagination. He put
it out of his mind and continued about his day.
He decided he would keep his eyes peeled for that
orange blur again though. Bill didn’t see anything
peculiar the rest of the morning and went to a
local café for lunch. He ordered a coffee and
a cream cheese bagel, then made a quick trip
to the bathroom while his food was prepared.
When Bill returned to his table though, he
was something strange. Instead of a bagel,
there was a large helping of lasagne on the table.
What was going on? This café didn’t even serve
lasagne. Bill knew something was terribly wrong.
Things only got stranger when Bill came home to
find a small tuft of orange fur snagged on
the frame of his front door. And it wasn’t
synthetic fur like you see on plush toys or
stuffed animals. No, this was real animal
fur. Maybe someone was just goofing off
or trying to play some weird prank on him,
but it didn’t feel like it. Deep down, Bill Murray
knew that he was in grave danger. Whoever, or
whatever, was behind this… it wanted to hurt him.
That night, his worst fears were realized. Bill’s
wife had left town for the week and he was heading
to the kitchen in the middle of the night for a
glass of water, when he saw something - A huge
figure moving up against the glass door leading
to his backyard. The thing was huge, nearly seven
feet tall, with a bloated, fur-covered, misshapen
body that was pressed up against the door. Its
fur was bright, garish orange – a cartoon orange.
Strangest of all though was the sound it
was making. It sounded like it was purring.
Bill backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide. The whole night,
he sat cowering as he heard scratching
against the walls, like something was
trying to get in. He was terrified and too
scared to do anything, even move. Finally,
as morning broke, the noises seemed to stop.
Bill had to do something. He couldn’t let this
nightmare go on another night. What if things got
worse? What if that thing managed to get inside?
He called the local police and when they arrived,
he explained the incredibly strange situation
as best he could. He told them he was being
stalked by some kind of huge cat, or at least
someone dressed like a huge cat. Also there was
lasagne involved. The officers interviewing him
could barely contain their laughter as he told
them his story. A giant orange cat? Perhaps,
one of them theorized, he’d angered some kind of
obsessive Garfield fan through his involvement
in the vive action movie. After all, the
original comic had been running for years
and had been extremely popular. Who knows what
kind of nut jobs were obsessed with seeing only
a faithful adaptation of the source material?
As the officers departed, Bill was confident that
they weren’t taking him seriously. He couldn’t
rely on any of them for protection. Thankfully,
from a multi-decade movie career,
he had plenty of disposable income,
and decided to hire a private security team to
protect him while he looked into this mystery.
He had two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month. They
were armed, and given the cryptic orders to fire
on anything orange. Meanwhile, Bill began to fall
down a Garfield rabbit hole. He felt strangely
compelled to research all the Garfield media he
could find, as though the answer to his terrifying
situation was somehow hidden between the lines.
Bill explored the entire backlog of thousands of
comic strips. He read the books and interviews
with Jim Davis. He watched the cartoons and
straight-to-DVD animated movies. Ironically for
a guy who’d recently portrayed the lasagne-loving
orange cat, Bill had never felt quite so immersed
in the character before. He found a strange
pathos in the routine of Garfield and his friends.
One particular comic really piqued his interest,
though. Originally published in October of 1989,
the comic began with Garfield being woken up by
a strange chill, an almost eerie sensation. The
character observed aloud that he didn’t feel like
he was in his own home. He explored his little
home further, trying to find his owner Jon or his
housemate and sometimes nemesis, Odie, but found
nothing. As Garfield remarked on feeling alone, a
purple speech box delivered the sinister message:
“You have no idea how alone you are,
Garfield.” He then finds that his home
looks like it’s been abandoned for years. The
“For Sale” sign outside is practically ancient.
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying revelation:
Everyone really is gone, and his adventures and
friends now exist only in his imagination.
He’s trapped in a prison of his own creation,
trying to stave off his endless loneliness, in
denial about the reality of his situation. The
comic ended with a quote directly from Jim Davis
himself, saying “An imagination is a powerful
tool. It can tint memories of the past, shade
perceptions of the present, or paint a future
so vivid that it can entice... or terrify, all
depending upon how we conduct ourselves today...”
As he read those words, Bill Murray felt a chill
down his spine. Why had he wanted to be involved
in the Garfield movie in the first place? What
had he gotten himself into? Before he could slip
any deeper into his own mind, Bill heard a faint,
choked scream downstairs. He felt his breath catch
in his throat. He was terrified but he needed to
see what was happening. He carefully and quietly
began to creep down the stairs. At the bottom, he
poked his head around a corner, and that’s when
he saw a member of his security detail lying dead
on the floor. His face was blue from asphyxiation,
his mouth was stuffed with lasagne. It
looked like he had been force-fed to death.
Bill wanted to scream but he couldn’t, or maybe
knew he shouldn’t. Just then he heard a soft,
meaty thumping noise coming from the nearby living
room. He didn’t know why, but he felt compelled to
approach as if by forces beyond his control. He
made his way to the living room, and when he got
there, he saw where the noise was coming from.
Bill’s jaw dropped in pure horror. There was
the other member of his security detail, lying
limp and lifeless under a giant orange figure.
It was a grotesquely huge creature, wearing what
looked to be a kind of crude Garfield outfit made
of sewn-together cat pelts. It stank of pasta and
rotten meat. In its giant paw, it held a golden
trophy, which it was using to pound the security
guard’s head into mush while making quiet,
cat-like purring noises. The creature suddenly
stopped and looked up, locking eyes with Bill.
The fear of death came over him. He froze,
as the giant, freakish Garfield stepped over
Donny’s corpse, and began to come towards him.
Bill turned and ran, but Garfield was gaining
on him. Before he could make it to the front door,
the creature knocked him over. He was laid out on
the ground, looking up at it, as it reached into
its own body cavity and began to pull out handfuls
of lasagne. He was just about to shove a wad of
the horrible decaying pasta into Bill’s mouth,
when suddenly, a DING was heard and
the creature stopped. It looked up,
as if sniffing the air, and then suddenly
turned and lumbered towards the kitchen.
Bill watched as the Garfield monster
entered the kitchen where, somehow,
there was a steaming hot fresh lasagne sitting
in the open oven. The creature had sensed the
presence of external lasagne, and felt the
compulsion to integrate it into its body,
grabbing fistfulls and shoving it into itself.
Just then, a group of highly trained SCP
Foundation personnel burst into the room
and subdued the creature. It had been an ambush.
The Foundation had been tipped off to the presence
of the creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches, and the report of a seven
foot tall comic book cat terrorizing a Hollywood
actor was definitely worth looking into. The
monster that had almost taken Bill Murray’s life
was SCP – 3166, a deadly pataphysical being that
tends to manifest around people somehow involved
in the Garfield intellectual property. It appears
whenever the public perception of Garfield falls
out of favor, and because Bill had starred in the
critically-panned Garfield movie, he was currently
at the very top of SCP – 3166’s hit list.
Thankfully, he managed to survive his
terrifying ordeal, and was administered
amnestics by Foundation personnel so
he could return to his normal life.
This frightening and mysterious creature
had been around since 1989, appearing after
the publication of the haunting Garfield
comic that Bill had read that very night.
It appeared in the office of United Media, who
were the publishers of the Garfield comic strip
at the time, and began wreaking havoc. Since
then, the creature’s manifestation has been
a constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience. As a result,
the Foundation has spent years as the funding
source behind all Garfield media, and even
planting hypnotic memetics into the comic strips
to ensure that there is always a loyal fanbase.
The fur is indeed real, organic cat fur, albeit an
unnaturally orange color, and instead of organs,
the creature is filled with lasagne. Worst
of all though, is that testing has revealed
that the meat in the lasagne is genetically
identical to the flesh of Garfield’s creator,
Jim Davis. How did this thing come into existence?
Perhaps it was Jim’s sheer force of imagination
that dragged it into being. As he himself
said, “An imagination is a powerful tool.”
All in all, it’s lucky that Bill Murray was
able to survive his encounter, and return to
his normal life – well, as normal as life can
be for Bill Murray. And if you see Bill Murray,
don’t bother asking him about SCP –
3166. The amnestics were quite effective,
and just as he’s fond of saying
himself, no one will ever believe you.
In a remote part of Russia, a mysterious disease
outbreak was tearing through a tiny farming
village with terrifying side effects. There was
no cure, no clue to where it came from, and worst
of all, the disease’s terrifying impact didn’t
end with death. No, it was after those carrying
the disease died, that the real horror started.
After an agonizing fever that leaves the victims
writhing in pain, they quickly succumb to
the disease, only to rise from their graves
to wreak havoc on the living. The virus
continues to spread, until the corpses
outnumber those trying to hide from them, as
the world spirals into almost certain ruin.
It sounds like the plot of a zombie movie, but for
the SCP Foundation this is anything but fiction,
and the terror that unfolded in that little
Siberian town is the first recorded encounter with
SCP - 610, also known as, The Flesh That Hates.
First, livestock began to vanish from farms. Theft
or wild animals were suspected, but no suspects
could be found, and no mutilated remains turned
up. The animals weren’t being stolen, and they
weren’t being eaten, so…what happened to them?
With no more animals left to lose, the
farmers themselves then began to disappear,
but the authorities refused to take the missing
persons cases seriously. The missing farmers’
families would contact the police, make
a report, and then the whole thing was
forgotten. It was written off as just another
unsolved disappearance, which wasn’t uncommon
in the wild and unforgiving region. Then
the police themselves began to disappear.
The families of the missing farmers would
sometimes report strange sounds from the
surrounding woods, describing moans and
inhuman screeches of pain. One young boy
reported seeing a cow with what he described as
“tentacles” lurking around the edge of the trees.
Regional police were dispatched to the location,
and ordered to investigate and report back on
their findings within 24 hours. But the units
sent to the area didn’t report back, and were
never heard from again. Upon learning of the
reports, the Russian government grew increasingly
concerned, fearing domestic insurgency or foreign
espionage of some kind could be at play. They sent
a small team of special agents to the area,
and, one by one, those agents disappeared,
just like the others before them.
It seemed no one who went into the
village after the disappearances started ever
came out again. They had all simply vanished.
Desperate for answers, the Russian government
contacted the only people in the world who could
help - The SCP Foundation. What the Foundation
found over the course of their investigation
would shock and unnerve them, going beyond
anything they had previously discovered.
Before the investigation officially began, the
affected area was sealed off by the Russian
government. Not knowing if it would be safe to
send researchers into the containment perimeter,
the Foundation set up a small camera mounted
unit, nicknamed Herbie, to capture footage of
whatever remained of the village. The images
captured by Herbie revealed what exactly had
become of the people in this doomed village,
and the true, nightmarish nature of SCP-610.
SCP-610 is a Keter-class entity, meaning
it’s an anomaly that’s exceedingly difficult
to contain consistently or reliably, with
containment procedures often being extensive
and complex. 610 is a highly contagious skin
disease that initially manifests like an
ordinary allergic reaction, with symptoms
including increased sensitivity, itching,
and a rash. But within just three hours of
those initial symptoms appearing, the rash
starts to turn into masses of scar tissue on the
chest and arms. These masses spread over the legs
and back of the victim, and completely consume
them in thick, rubbery flesh within five hours.
Once they’re covered, the victim will cease
all vital functions. Unfortunately for them,
and doubly so for those around them, they do not
stay dead. About three minutes after expiring,
the victim’s vitals will restart at a heightened
rate, and the masses of flesh encasing their body
will begin to move and multiply, mutating them
into a form beyond anything resembling the human
they once were. The specific type of mutation
varies from case to case, but has included the
head becoming massive and bulbous, the growth of
extra limbs, and, in especially gruesome cases,
the victim’s body splitting apart to allow extra
tendrils of flesh to sprout from the open wound.
Occasionally, an infected person will stop moving
and become rooted to the ground in a set location.
Once it is settled, their flesh will spread
itself across the ground, encasing all nearby
objects in flaps of scar tissue. The infected that
maintain their mobility are highly aggressive,
even violent, and will attempt to infect
any living thing that comes into their
line of sight. The disease does not only infect
humans, and can take over any living organism
within a matter of hours. Due to the highly
contagious and dangerous nature of the disease,
safe observation of infected specimens and areas
is only possible with drones and mounted cameras.
This brings us back to Herbie,
the first such mounted camera
to record footage of the infected area.
Herbie was deployed into the infection site,
also known as Site A, without any damage.
It remained at the outside perimeter of the
village for two hours, observing several infected
humans, and fire damage to many of the homes,
before following an infected into an intact house.
Herbie’s camera feed captured the infected person
entering the house and sitting down at the table
inside. There were several other infected humans
in the house, and one unidentified infected
creature that remained immobile under the table.
After viciously assaulting one of the other
infected humans, the infected returned to
the table and began to lay out plates on top
of it. Pieces of its flesh began to wriggle
and tear away from its body, before settling
onto each plate. Once the plates were filled,
the infected sitting at the table began to grab
at the flesh and crush it into their mouths, in a
perverse imitation of a normal mealtime gathering.
After capturing this stomach-churning display,
Herbie left the house and continued to explore
the village. It recorded footage of a large
stack of bodies that seemed to be made up
of both Russian military and civilians,
with an infected sitting on top. As Herbie
maneuvered toward the remains of the town hall,
an infected grabbed the rover off of the ground.
Herbie’s camera was able to capture the face of
the infected that grabbed the rover. The face
was that of a young girl around ten years old,
strangely intact atop a large, distorted body.
The final moments of Herbie’s camera feed captured
the infected girl’s face bursting open,
revealing tendrils of flesh that pulled
Herbie into the gaping maw. Then, the feed
cut to black. Herbie was regarded as lost,
but the video feed briefly resumed five hours
later, showing the camera covered with an
unidentified slime. After this, the video feed
was cut for good, and Herbie abandoned in Site A.
The Foundation has sent several manned expeditions
into Site A, where many expedition forces have
fallen victim to the infected. Several operatives
were also lost in an earthquake that revealed
a network of underground tunnels. A manned
expedition into these tunnels was attempted,
and the video feed that was captured
by the researchers on the expedition
was deeply disturbing. There were images of
an abandoned church filled with infected,
and a mass of uninfected or partially infected
human captives. The final moments of the video
feed from this expedition captured
several operatives being murdered by
an infected human wielding a farming scythe,
indicating that the infected are capable of
using simple weaponry in addition to brute force.
The use of this weapon, paired with the presence
of captives in the underground tunnels,
paints a terrifying picture of the kind
of organization the infected are capable of. No
more manned expeditions have been attempted, or,
if they have, they have been highly classified.
Ordinarily, once a new SCP is discovered,
it is placed in containment at the Foundation,
with special procedures in place, so that it
can be studied or even neutralized in the rare
occasions where it’s deemed necessary. When it
comes to SCP-610 though, containment might just be
impossible. It simply covers too much area, and is
too dangerous to expose to human researchers.
Instead, all infected areas have been isolated
with the permission of the Russian government.
There is an official perimeter established around
these areas, and any civilians that approach them
are told to leave under the pretense of ongoing
military operations. For once, a top secret
military project is the more innocent answer.
Armed guards are placed at the perimeter
of every infected area, and any living
thing with symptoms of SCP-610 spotted near
the perimeter is to be immobilized, killed,
and burned from as far away as possible. Any
living thing that comes in contact with SCP-610,
whether a soldier, a scientist, or a civilian,
is immediately terminated, and their remains
destroyed. If someone comes within three
meters of an infected organism, they will
be quarantined and remotely examined to determine
if they have been infected. While the spread of
SCP-610 can be airborne, it has been determined
to be far less contagious when spread through
air particles as opposed to physical contact.
The infection sites remain active to this day,
like modern day leper colonies. Though they
are isolated from the general population,
and the military is doing everything in their
power to contain the infected, SCP-610 is still
very much alive. It is rare for an entity to
exist that the Foundation cannot truly contain,
but can only try to guard against, and that makes
this infection all the more terrifying. Who knows
how much it has mutated over the years, growing,
spreading, hungry for new hosts? There is still so
much that the Foundation does not know about
the Flesh That Hates, such as how it works,
what it can do, or even where it came from,
since the origin of the first infection
is still, at this point, entirely unknown.
It has shown itself to be capable of learning,
planning, and protecting itself, so who is to say
that it couldn’t figure out a way to escape from
its isolated area? It is so highly contagious,
and spreads so quickly, that just one tiny,
infected rabbit, and one inattentive soldier,
could be enough for SCP-610 to reach the general
population. If it did, its violent, destructive
nature and hatred for all life would mean that
everything, not just the people but animals,
plants, and the world itself, could be at risk.
And no one is ready for this kind of infection. A
disease that turns the human body against itself,
turns our skin into a weapon and a tomb,
stripping away identity, humanity, and
everything that isn’t made of that same hateful
flesh. So, let’s hope that the perimeter holds,
and, the next time you feel a little itchy,
try not to think about what might happen next.
ou might be able to avert this horrible fate, if
only you knew what exactly you were dealing with:
SCP – 4666, also known as The Yule Man. A
Keter-Class Christmas monster so violent,
sadistic, and terrifying, he makes Krampus
look like jolly Saint Nick. And this year,
just like every other, he’s planning
on being very, very naughty.
The SCP Foundation began cataloguing the Yule
Man in 1974 after a string of violent and
eerily similar home invasions during the holiday
season, but they have reason to believe that this
entity has been around for a whole lot longer.
Over 2000 years in fact. Stories that describe
what look to be Yule Man massacres date as far
back as the First Century BC in Scandinavia,
and there have been reports of similar clusters
of events happening around the same time every
year since. This monster is prolific, and
may have one of the highest body counts of
any creature under observation by the Foundation.
The Yule Man’s trail of destruction became clearer
in the eighteenth century, as accounts of the
carnage it leaves became more detailed. Later
still, authorities even managed to find physical
evidence like the Yule Man’s fingerprints – which
are similar to human fingerprints, but display
a distinct double-whorl pattern not seen in
human fingerprints. Much about the anomalous
nature of the Yule Man is still unknown though,
and the Foundation has yet to discover an
effective way to contain it. Their only
hope is intercepting it before it can get its
long, gnarled fingers on its intended prey.
Maybe you’re feeling worried, or that you’re being
watched. You have a good reason to be afraid,
because during his yearly active period – the
twelve days between December 21st and January
2nd – he’s always searching for prey. Nowhere is
safe, because while it was initially believed that
he only appeared to those who lived north of 40
degrees latitude, it’s now believed that much like
Santa Claus, the Yule Man operates worldwide.
Anyone could be in his sights right now,
blissfully unaware of the nightmare coming
down the tracks towards them. Thankfully,
the SCP Foundation, through analysis of these
attacks which are known as Weissnacht Events,
they’ve been able to find certain patterns.
But first, what does the creature known as
The Yule Man even look like? Much like SCP –
096, the Yule Man is a long and lanky humanoid
standing about two meters tall, who resembles
an emaciated human of European descent,
and never wears any clothes or other coverings
despite the frigid temperatures he operates in.
You might be sad if you’re spending Christmas
alone, but it at least guarantees you safety
from the Yule Man, as he only appears at
the homes of families with a child under
the age of eight present. He also seems
to favor isolated and rural locations,
and Weissnacht Events only occur when there’s a
healthy covering of snow on the ground during the
event – hence the name which means “White Night”
in English. It’s also vital that you recognize
the three distinct stages of a Weissnacht Event,
too, or you won’t be seeing much of the New Year.
The first stage occurs during the space of
a week. Children in the home might start to
seem worried or afraid. They might tell you that
they see something strange in the distance. The
figure of a man they don’t recognize, standing
just far enough away that you can’t fully make
him out, except that he’s really tall. Of
course, you probably won’t see anything,
and your instinct will be to tell them there’s
nothing to be afraid of. Even when they tell you,
through tears, that there’s a man pressing his
face up against their bedroom window at night.
But they are right to be afraid, and you
should be, too. Already at this point,
your only hope is to try and spread the word as
soon as possible: Report the incident to the local
police, write about it on Facebook, tweet about
it. Whatever it takes. The SCP Foundation has
operatives trawling the internet and monitoring
police reports constantly during this period,
especially for reports of mysterious men in the
snow watching homes from a distance. Getting the
Foundation’s attention is your best hope
of stopping this thing. And if you don’t?
Next comes stage two, taking place between
nights eight and eleven of the active period.
No longer will the Yule Man just be lurking on
the periphery. Now he’s getting closer. You’ll
start to hear strange noises in your attic or on
the roof, noises that sound almost like footsteps.
That’s crazy, you think, it’s probably just an
animal. But then, the smell starts. An awful,
rotten stench that fills the house, but no matter
how hard you look, you can’t find the source.
Finally, on the last night of December, you
tell yourself that you’ll take this matter to
the police. But of course, it’s already too
late. The Yule Man is here for the twelfth
night. The Weissnacht is finally upon you.
At this point, one of two scenarios will
happen. In the first, you and your entire
family will be tortured and murdered,
except the youngest child, who the Yule Man
will kidnap. The SCP Foundation keeps files
on a number of notable instances of this kind of
Weissnacht, and the details are truly gruesome.
Reports of incidents have involved crucifixion,
the removal of tongues, burning, dismemberment,
post mortem bitemarks, and decapitation.
In all instances though, the entire family
was killed except the youngest child, who simply
disappeared. The Yule Man is a merciless and
sadistic beast. You’re now probably wondering: If
that’s the first of two Weissnacht possibilities,
what’s the second? In the second, if you’re
tremendously lucky, you and your family will
survive – but that doesn’t mean you won’t face a
grisly experience. In this scenario, which occurs
during about fifteen percent of Weissnacht Events,
you’ll hear footsteps throughout the night,
but thankfully, you wake up alive. And when
you do so, there are gifts waiting for you.
The problem is, all these gifts are made out of
human body parts. For example, in 1976 in Canada,
one family received the gift of a ball made
from a severed human head wrapped in skin. In
Kazakhstan in 1903, a family received a flute
made from a hollowed out human femur. And in the
Netherlands in 2003, a family received a wooden
hairbrush, covered in human teeth ranging from 400
years old to a mere few days. These gruesome gifts
are referred to as SCP – 4666 – A, and it was one
of these gifts that gave us the best insight yet
available into the true nature of the Yule Man.
Several gifts were dropped off at a family's
residence in Hoonah, Alaska, in 2018,
but most notable among them was the horrific
SCP-4666-A-0960 – a life-sized doll made from
a human body, with its eyes removed and mouth sewn
shut. Worst of all though, was that the girl was
still alive. The family who received this twisted
gift was given amnestics by the Foundation, and
the living doll was taken for medical treatment.
Before succumbing to her extensive injuries,
the girl was able to deliver some insights
into what exactly happened to the children
who were abducted during Weissnacht Events.
The children taken by the Yule Man are forced
into a large sack that seems much bigger on the
inside than it appears as he makes his rounds,
travelling from house to house, murdering
and kidnapping. His victims are taken to a
kind of underground grotto and workshop filled
with bones, like a twisted Santa’s workshop,
where they’re forced to make toys out of the
bodies of their fellow victims. During this time,
the Yule Man will continue to torture and torment
his victims. He’ll even take some of them away to
cook and eat whenever he feels like it.
When asked how she was turned into this
human doll, the girl told Foundation personnel
that her fellow victims were forced to turn her
into this by the Yule Man when she became
too weak to continue making toys herself.
Her chilling last words were, “When you
can’t make the toys, you become the toys.”
So if strange things happen to you and your
family between the 21st of December and the 1st
of January, don’t ignore it. After all, you never
know who’s watching. But if it is the Yule Man’s
grinning face pressed up against your window,
it may already be too late. Happy Holidays…
There is a dangerous creature that could be
anywhere in the world, hiding in plain sight,
casually walking through crowded streets
filled with people. A monster that is
nearly impossible to see, blending into its
surroundings almost perfectly. Not invisible,
but unnoticeable, almost completely undetectable.
But then, you spot a familiar outfit in a crowd.
You now know where the creature is. But it goes
both ways, since the moment you find it, it knows
where you are. There is now not a single place on
the Earth that you could hide where it wouldn’t
find you. And it won’t ever stop looking. To the
staff at the Foundation this creature is known as
SCP-4885. But you and I know him by a different
name. You may have seen his face hundreds of
times, or stared for hours at a page trying
to catch a glimpse of him. To us, he’s Waldo.
While this might feel like a very long-winded
and silly joke, maybe even a prank that has
been inserted into the SCP archives, it
is anything but. If you grew up any time
after the elate 1980s, then you will likely
be familiar with the Where’s Waldo? books,
but for the uninitiated, these are a series
of puzzle books created by illustrator Martin
Handford. Each book in the Where’s Waldo? line
contains multiple double-page spreads of colorful,
crowded scenes. The goal is for readers to
spot the ever-elusive titular character, Waldo,
who is hidden among the mass of other characters.
Waldo himself is easily recognized, thanks to
a design that has become truly iconic over the
years. He is always depicted as wearing a red and
while striped shirt, with a bobble hat in matching
colors. Waldo also sports jeans, circular rimmed
glasses, and sometimes a wooden walking stick.
So, with that important context out of the way
up front, what exactly is SCP-4885? Is it the
character from these children’s books somehow
brought to life? Has the character of Waldo
always been a malicious, malevolent entity,
too powerful to be contained within his own books?
Well, not exactly. SCP-4885 only seems to resemble
the famous children’s book character. Whether or
not he is a living manifestation of Waldo in the
real world is both unclear and up for debate.
Examining its outward appearance, SCP-4885 does
share the humanoid shape and looks to be
wearing the same recognizable clothing of
Waldo. There are, however, two notable bodily
dissimilarities between the Waldo on the page,
and the physical form of SCP-4885. For one, this
Waldo appears to be much paler to the one found
in the book series. More noticeably however, is
the fact that, despite wearing the same circular
glasses, SCP-4885 seems to have no eyes.
Should a person learn of SCP-4885’s current
location, Waldo will simultaneously gain an
awareness of this person. Learning instantly of
their victim’s location, SCP-4885 will traverse
any space necessary, tracking their target down
to anywhere they might be in the world. The
creature has displayed a number of space altering
abilities, including teleportation. SCP-4885
can also alter the state of his own matter,
allowing Waldo to phase through solid surfaces.
No obstacle can stop his advance: not walls,
not buildings, not even his victim’s own body.
When SCP-4885 finally reaches the person who has
learned of his location, Waldo will then proceed
to murder them in an exceptionally excruciating
manner. Using his matter changing abilities, he
will teleport or phase himself inside his victim,
pulling himself through their body and destroying
their internal organs. After causing catastrophic
bodily damage, SCP-4885 will then wrench
their victim’s jaw open, unhinging it with
enough force to climb his way out of their mouth,
leaving them dead, their body completely mangled.
However, this isn’t even the final stage of
Waldo’s attack. There is a strange by-product
left after a fatal encounter with SCP-4885, a
yellow liquid that is produced as Waldo exits
his victim’s body. When this substance comes
into contact with the deceased person’s skin,
it triggers a bizarre change. The liquid will
cause their bodies to change after death,
their skin becoming covered in symbols.
On closer inspection is becomes clear that
these symbols are illustrations, exactly like
the ones found in the pages of Where’s Waldo?
These corpses, referred to by the Foundation
as instances of SCP-4855-1, will then start
to act in a similar manner to SCP-4885, and
anyone who sees one or learns of its location
will cause Waldo to come looking for them.
The Where’s Waldo? scenes left on a deceased
victim’s skin cannot be washed off or otherwise
removed and the only way to undo an instance
of SCP-4885-1 is to skin an infected body after
death. However, this creates a whole new problem.
If someone was to attempt this, in doing so they
would know the location of one of Waldo’s victims.
This knowledge would mean that whomever was trying
to skin one of these bodies would themselves
become Waldo’s next target and would likely end
up just another instance of SCP-4885-1. In other
words, it would be an exercise in futility.
Naturally, the nature of his abilities and
attack patterns makes it difficult for the
SCP Foundation to contain Waldo. SCP-4885
cannot be harmed through the use of firearms,
or other common, conventional weapons at the
Foundation’s disposal. You might be forgiven for
thinking that making a handful of people aware
of where to find Waldo at the same time would
be a viable solution. After all, he cannot be
in multiple places at once, so perhaps he’d be
unable to kill these individuals simultaneously.
However, SCP-4885 has shown to be able
to cope with this approach, dispatching
his victims one at a time, transforming each
in turn into Where’s Waldo? printed corpses,
before continuing to the next would-be victim.
If the victim is nearby, Waldo will force
himself into their mouth, passing through
their body and destroying bones, organs,
and even the spinal column. When his victim
is further away, Waldo will phase through the
nearest wall and attack them, teleporting into
his target and then climbing out of their mouth.
Waldo’s location, or that of his victims’ bodies,
are considered ‘infohazards’. Simply being aware
of this information will cause SCP-4885 to
activate. As a result of this, the staff at
the SCP Foundation are not even sure that Waldo is
actually contained at all. In theory, SCP-4885 is
being held at an undisclosed Foundation site
within a non-designated containment chamber,
since even a number on the door would tip off
what’s inside, triggering Waldo’s abilities. But,
here’s the clincher; because nobody can know for
sure where Waldo is without him coming for them,
nobody at the Foundation actually knows
where he’s being contained, if he’s even
contained at all! It is worth noting
that, if someone receives a vague,
non-specific description of Waldo’s whereabouts,
then he will make no attempt to seek them out.
If he is contained, and if he was to ever breach
containment, then the SCP Foundation has an entire
set of procedures in place to ensure that no one
ever finds Waldo. First, 36 containment chambers
identical to the one SCP-4885 is supposedly
held in are connected to a self-driving
vehicle. An expendable D-Class personnel member
is placed into the vehicle and a random number
generator will select a number from one to 36.
The self-driving vehicle will then arrive at the
containment chamber chosen at random, and the
D-Class placed inside. Within each chamber are
digital monitors, and once the D-Class is inside
a chamber, all of these monitors will display
the current location of SCP-4885. The Foundation
has a GPS tracking device implanted within Waldo,
but this information is normally kept
secret to avoid any containment breaches.
The D-Class essentially acts as bait for Waldo,
forcibly given the knowledge of his location so
that SCP-4885 will consider them a target.
As part of the next phase of containment,
Foundation staff will wait, giving Waldo enough
time to arrive in the containment chamber and
dispatch the D-Class within. After this, all
of the 36 containment chambers are transported
to random Foundation sites in disguised trucks,
so that no one is sure where SCP-4885 ends up.
Every time SCP-4885 breaches containment,
the entire procedure has to be repeated.
The Foundation first encountered SCP-4885 a
number of years ago, inside a small wooden house,
the exact location of which has since been
expunged from all the SCP Foundation’s records.
While on an assignment to secure an entirely
different anomaly, the Foundation’s Mobile
Task Force Chi-19, also code named ‘Unrelenting
Punishment’, were the first to discover Waldo.
The three person unit consisted of
Foundation operatives named Amelia Merrick,
James Klein and Kurt Stoll. The trio cautiously
entered the wooden house where they were
meant to investigate reports of an anomalous,
inanimate object: a pair of black spectacles.
According to initial intelligence gathered by
the SCP Foundation, these glasses were capable
of killing anyone that tried to wear them, leaving
their body covered in pictures like those found in
a children’s book. Sounds familiar, doesn’t
it? It is unknown if these black spectacles
are the same eyewear worn by SCP-4885, but
it doesn’t seem like too far of a leap to
assume that this may well have been the case.
Searching the ground floor, the team found no
sign of the object had been sent to recover. As
Amelia, Kurt, and James made their way upstairs,
something began making scraping sounds beneath
them, but none of them noticed. In an abandoned
bedroom on the upstairs floor of the house, Kurt
spotted a drawing on the wall, which looked to
have been made using crayons. He took a photo
of the illustration, and this image is still
kept in the Foundation’s database. It appears
to be a child’s drawing, depicting SCP-4885,
wearing his signature striped shirt and hat,
with empty, vacant eyes. Next to it was scrawled
one simple phrase: “Waldo found mommy.”
Continuing their way through the house,
the team located the glasses they were
looking for in an upstairs bathroom. However,
as James bagged up the spectacles, ready for
transport back to the Foundation, Kurt spotted
another inscription on a nearby wall, one that the
team were certain hadn’t been there when they had
arrived. James stepped in to translate it using
a Foundation standard issue translation device.
The phrase on the wall read “The basement. The
corpses from a child’s book are in the basement.
He is there too. Fr-.” And we’re sure that you
can already guess what happened after that.
Immediately after reading these words, James
began to groan and clutched at his stomach,
showing signs of extreme pain. Before Amelia
or Kurt had any chance to figure out what was
happening to their squadmate, fingers began
protruding from James’ mouth. They gripped
his jaw and pulled it apart with enough force
to send his jawbone flying across the room.
SCP-4885 climbed its way out of James’ body,
and Amelia and Kurt both opened fire on the
creature. Waldo did not react, seemingly
unphased by the gunfire and sustaining no
damage as he approached Amelia, who would be his
next victim. Showing his fingers into her throat,
Waldo wrenched apart Amelia’s jaw, breaking it
before he clawed his way into her mouth. As he
watched in horror, Kurt made a panicked call for
help to the Foundation, but it was too late. Waldo
had already dispatched both James and Amelia, and
now Kurt was about to pay the same terrible price.
Ever since this incident, the
Foundation believes that they have
SCP-4885 contained. When his file was created,
their researchers created an automated algorithm,
designed to wipe away any mention of
SCP-4885’s current location or the house
he was discovered in from Foundation records.
With SCP-4885 now assumed to be contained,
that only leaves one question, the same
burning inquiry that’s been plaguing
man for decades… Where’s Waldo? In this
case, maybe it’s safer if you don't know.
You’re a pizza delivery person for a company
we’re not at liberty to name. It may seem
like a thankless job, but you’re part of
the thin crust between satisfaction and
starvation for people who really don’t feel
like cooking or going out tonight. You’re
a tried and true pizza veteran. You’ve
seen a lot on the job - from people who
tried to rob you on their own doorsteps, to
one guy who tried to tip you with a clearly
fake Rolex - but you haven’t seen anything like
the insanity you’re about to encounter tonight.
That’s because you’re about to get sick. Really,
really sick. And we know there’s probably a lot of
diseases you’d rather not catch, but trust
us, no disease bites quite like SCP-3760.
But back to you. You’re parked on the saddle
of your prized bicycle, pedaling for your life,
the biggest order you’ve ever delivered
strapped to the cargo rack behind you - eight
large meat-feast pizzas. You figure you’re
heading towards the most hopping, or at least
the hungriest party in the city, and despite
the frustration of needing to ferry this hot,
cheesy nightmare to its destination, parties
have historically been pretty good tippers.
Little do you know, your prized customer is
about to give you much more than just a tip.
You pull up outside their ground level apartment
and park your bike. There’s no music coming from
the apartment you’re heading to. Strange. You
pick up your precious cargo and trudge towards
the door, barely managing to ring the bell with
your spare pinky. The door swings open instantly,
as though the occupant was just standing
behind it the whole time, waiting for you.
When the door opens, you’re not sure
what to make of what you see inside.
There isn’t a party. There doesn’t even
seem to be a group. Just one person,
standing there and staring at you, and
something about this person is just...wrong.
His skin seems to be an oddly unnatural color.
It has a slightly gray hue, like it’s rotting,
and you see that the stranger’s shirt
is torn in several places. You’re trying
your best to remain professional and not
stare, but you can’t help but notice that
whatever is under these tears doesn’t
look like skin. It’s almost like there
are holes all over his body underneath the
shirt - big, gaping holes. And are those…
You’re cut off when he takes the pile of
pizzas from you, and shoves what was once
a handful of dollars into your palm.
They seem torn up, and worst of all,
wet. You look past your strange customer, and
see that his apartment looks just as shoddy as
he does. There’s stuffing torn from the couch.
Huge tears in the curtains. What you could swear
are scratch or bite marks on some of the wooden
furniture. This man clearly needed his pizza.
As you begin to step away, happy to just be rid
of this freaky situation, you do something that
you’ll live to regret. Just for a moment, you
lock eyes with the customer. There’s something
about them that makes you feel sick. They’re wet
and black - more like a doll’s eyes than anything
that should belong to a human. Just that one
instant of contact is enough to chill your bones,
and according to some theories around SCP-3760,
it may have been the moment of your infection.
As the stranger closes the door
in your face, presumably to eat
his obscene number of pizzas, you stumble
back to your bicycle, letting your torn up,
gooey tip blow away in the wind. Getting
out of this place is rewarding enough. But
you can’t chase the thoughts of the stranger
out of your mind. Was he sick? Was he even
human? These are the thoughts swimming through
your head as you cycle back to the restaurant.
You’re so preoccupied, you don’t even notice the
truck speeding towards you. You get sideswiped,
destroying your bike and throwing you through the
air. You can feel the snap of your arm breaking as
you land. It’s a horrible feeling to go along
with the horrible noise. And as you fade from
consciousness, the last thought in your mind
is the black, soulless eyes of the customer.
When you wake up, you find that you’re in
a hospital bed with your arm in a cast. The
doctors tell you that you’re phenomenally lucky
to be alive given the severity of the crash. The
doctor says that you’re dealing with a compound
fracture in your right arm, as well as some nasty
cuts that required stitches, but otherwise
you’re fine. The hospital insists that you
at least stay the night though, and you oblige,
but that night you find it’s difficult to sleep.
Partly because of the pain, but mostly
because of an extremely strange sound
coming from inside the cast around
your arm. It’s a scraping noise,
like something sharp scratching at the
interior. You figure it must just be some
strange side effect of the pain meds - you’re
not going to let worry eat you up inside.
Something else will be doing that soon enough.
You’re discharged from the hospital the
next day and told that you should be fine
in a couple months, as though that’s some
kind of consolation. You try to carry on
with your daily life, as much as you
can with one arm out of commission,
but that awful crunching noise from inside
your cast persists. You even start to
become paranoid that some sort of insect is
trapped inside, or worse, a swarm of insects.
But you aren’t left with that uncertainty for
long. By the next morning, your cast has fallen
off. Well, not “fallen”, per se. A more accurate
description would be that it was chewed off from
the inside. And not by something trapped in
there with your arm, but by your arm itself.
When you finally see it, it doesn’t
even look like an arm anymore:
The flesh has turned gray. That same
sickly gray of the customer’s skin,
the night of your accident. But worse still:
From the top of the hand down to the base
of the forearm, your entire arm is split
open into a fang-lined, chattering mouth.
When you’ve gotten over the initial horror of
seeing the mutations that have taken hold of your
arm, you notice something about the teeth in the
second mouth: They’re nothing like human teeth,
they’re vicious, jagged triangles, each
one like a dagger. These are unmistakably
shark’s teeth. You give yourself the luxury of
having a good scream - After all, what else are
you supposed to do after you find your arm has
turned into some kind of fleshy shark mutant.
You notice that you can hardly even feel the
snapping of its jaws, like it isn’t even really
a part of you. And as much as you try to tense
and release what used to be the tendons in your
forearm, there is no change. For all intents and
purposes, that limb is no longer yours, it just
happens to be attached to you. Not only that, but
it’s always very, very hungry, as quickly became
evident from the fact it made such short work of
the cast that’d been containing it not long ago.
You can see that the graying flesh is beginning
to spread from your forearm to your bicep. It’s
almost like, little by little, your
tissue is being switched. Somehow,
you’re innately aware that if you don’t
feed your arm, it’ll get even worse.
Suddenly, everything about the strange customer
from the night of the accident makes sense:
He had whatever you have now, only worse.
He was just hoping that the pizzas would
keep the beast at bay, and you very much hope
the contents of your fridge will do the same.
Wasting no time, you grab some processed
ham and raw chicken - you’re not an idiot,
you know that if this thing is anything like
a real shark, it’s only going to be interested
in meat. But when you shove the processed meat
into the nibbling maw in your forearm, you notice
that it seems to spit the food out. Something
tells you that your offering was too… dead.
Now, you’re really afraid. Will this thing want
live prey? Will that be the only way to stop it
from taking the rest of your arm, or even more?
The thought terrifies you. It’s like being Venom,
except you don’t even get a new alien friend or
any cool superpowers for your trouble. But you’re
smart; you’re resourceful. You don’t intend to let
this thing take over your life without a fight,
and you’ve always believed what GI Joe
taught you: Knowing is half the battle.
Sadly, doing an internet search for “My
injury is somehow mutating into a shark,
how do I stop this” didn’t do much good.
And you don't want to go to a doctor,
because part of you expects to be immediately
shipped off to the nearest circus or military
research lab. Instead, you throw on a thick
leather jacket that you hope your new shark-arm
will take a while to eat through, and head to
the library of the nearest medical college. If
anywhere has sources on the most obscure of
medical problems, this would be the place.
And after hours of searching through index
cards, you find it - what seems to be the
one and only source on this ludicrous topic in
the thousands and thousands of books: A series
of journal entries made by Dr. Keith Woodward,
Ship's Medical Officer aboard the USS Kirby,
circa 1922. Even the library’s indexing system
prefaces the source with a disclaimer that it’s
likely 25% quackery and 75% ocean madness, but
that doesn’t deter you. Any port in a storm.
Dr. Woodward told the horrifying tale of the USS
Kirby’s collapse due to a sudden and unexplainable
contagion. It began with the infection of
a sailor on the ship named Willis Riggs,
who’d fallen overboard and had his foot partially
eaten by a shark. Much like your arm, the man’s
foot slowly became the ravenous, all-devouring
mouth of a shark itself. Little by little,
it spread to other crew members through
unknown means. Any injuries sustained by
the crew didn’t heal like normal, but instead
became this vicious, living shark tissue.
Soon, these ever-hungry new mouths led them
to eat each other, and then themselves,
from inside out. Even after the humans they
once were could be considered long dead,
those hungry jaws kept snapping. There
was no cure. There was no solution.
Everyone on the boat was recorded
as having mysteriously died at sea.
That is the curse of SCP-3760.
As if on cue, you look down to see that the
shark mouth in your arm has chewed through the
leather of your sleeve like it’s nothing.
It’s hungry, and nothing will satiate it.
But perhaps some sacrifices need to be made
if you want to stop it from getting worse…
Just as the thought crosses your mind, a
needle full of sedative is injected into
your neck. Everything goes dark very quickly,
and when you wake up, you’re in a clean,
clinical white room. You’re now officially
under containment by the SCP Foundation,
not that you’ll know that any time soon.
This may seem like the cavalry has arrived,
but sadly for your sake, they
have no interest in curing you.
They’re just eager to gather more data on
how your condition progresses. SCP-3760
exists as a latent infection in well
over half of humanity, but its horrific,
mutating effects are activated in only a relative
few. There have only been 2,785 recorded cases of
SCP-3760 activity observed between 1958 and 2016.
This is thanks to the Foundation’s secret weapon
against the shark mutation menace - Subliminal
Memetic Agent Kappa/Omicron - or "SMA-K/O" - a
widely distributed memetic agent that suppresses
the symptoms of infection in most people. Not
that this will provide much comfort to you,
as you join the almost 3,000 others who have
been infected and you are doomed to slowly turn
into an abomination in your containment chamber.
If it’s any consolation, you may not see the truly
advanced stages of the disease. The most common
cause of death among the afflicted is being eaten
by their own ravenous shark mouths long before it
changes your entire body. Actually, come to think
of it, that’s not much of a consolation at all.
But hey, when it comes to anomalous mutations,
we’re sad to report that there’s rarely a happy
ending in store for those afflicted, and
SCP-3760 is no exception to the rule.
Why do so many of the indigenous cultures of
the colder regions of North America seem to
share the same legend? A legend that tells
of a monster that lurks in the forests,
bringing cold and death to any that meet
it. This creature is an omen of famine, a
territorial beast that preys on human beings. Some
cultures describe it as an unholy abomination,
a spirit of winter and a warning against the
dangers of selfishness, one that is created
whenever a person resorts to cannibalism in order
to survive. It will gladly devour any man, woman
or child that wanders into its territory, holding
a horrifying and insatiable hunger for human
flesh. So how did so many cultures end up with
the same story? Could it be because… it’s real?
Depictions of the beast vary, but it is most
commonly recognized by its tall, skeletal form,
like a body exhumed from the grave, even
carrying the stench of death and decay with
it. Anyone who encounters one risks being eaten
or transformed into a creature just like. The
monster’s name means an ‘evil spirit that devours
mankind’ though to even say the name is taboo,
as it’s believed to give power to the beast.
Of course, these are all just legends,
right? Stories to warn against the dangers of
greed and selfishness, but otherwise nothing
to fear. There’s no proof that such a beast
could actually be roaming the frozen wastes?
Many at the SCP Foundation
felt the same way, until they
heard about SCP-323, the Wendigo’s Skull.
Kept under lock and key by the Foundation
with around the clock surveillance, SCP-323
is an anomalous object with ties to the
various Wendigo legends. As the object’s moniker
suggests, SCP-323 is a skull; not a human skull,
mind you, it more closely resembles a cervid
skull. Cervids are a family of mammals that
include most varieties of deer, elk, and
other similar animals, and this particular
cervid skull sports a tall pair of antlers.
SCP-323 is definitely not a fresh skull either.
It shows signs of weathering and a few scars
across the surface, looking as if the bone has
been bleached and eroded through exposure to the
elements. The skull is also missing its lower jaw,
and has a sizable hole on the rear underside
that may have been carved using stone tools.
SCP-323 is kept restrained inside an armored
container within a concrete containment cell, and
personnel are only ever allowed near it to check
the restraints for signs of damage. Additionally,
any Foundation staff that enter SCP-323’s cell
must be accompanied by an armed security officer,
and in the event of a containment breach the
entire site is to be evacuated. Seems like a
lot of precautions and safety measures for an old
piece of bone. Surely a harmless deer skull could
never be that dangerous, right?
Wrong.
You might be forgiven for thinking that a
skull can’t possibly cause harm. After all,
SCP-323 is just a skull, then whatever animal it
belonged to is dead. But this skull is far more
than it appears to be. Through extensive testing,
the SCP Foundation’s researchers have learned that
the skull… isn’t dead. No, this skull is awake and
aware. It can see, hear and has a sense of touch,
and it can and will react to various stimuli.
However, this does not necessarily mean that
SCP-323 is alive or even sentient, but
it definitely appears to have some level
of sapience. It will target certain members of
personnel that get too close and has attempted
multiple times to breach containment. It
also reacts violently to anyone speaking
English or French near it, the only two
languages prohibited inside SCP-323’s cell.
So, while the skull is not technically alive, it
is definitely aware. Still, why the need for so
many protocols to keep it contained? It’s not
as if a skull can just walk off on its own. Of
course not, but SCP-323 can move, at least to a
certain degree. Often in a reactionary manner,
SCP-323 will vibrate or move on its own. For
example, turning to watch as personnel enter its
containment cell. In most cases, these movements
are tiny and insignificant. But other times,
the skull lunges, launching itself at Foundation
personnel as it desperately tries to get free.
Now you know why it’s kept restrained.
So, we have an antlered cervid skull that
can move and has a low level of awareness, on
their own these would be more than enough to
warrant the Foundation’s interest, but the
anomalous properties of SCP-323 don’t stop
there. The skull has an inherent ability to
influence the minds of those around it. Anyone
spending an hour within a fifteen-meter radius
of SCP-323 is likely to experience the effects
of this influential power. This will often result
in them exhibiting uncharacteristic behaviors,
thoughts, and urges, including cannibalistic
tendencies and outbursts of random violence.
Almost three quarters of people that suffer the
influence of SCP-323 will feel an overwhelming
compulsion to take the Wendigo’s Skull and fit
their heads into the chiseled hole on its rear
underside. If someone attempting this finds that
their head is too big to fit inside the hollow
skull, there have been cases of individuals
trying to bludgeon their heads on any hard
surface they can find nearby in an attempt to
get their head down to a more manageable size.
This will continue until one of three outcomes
occurs: one, the person manages to fit their
head into the skull. Two, they cause themselves
so much cranial damage that they are rendered
unconscious. Or three, they end up killing
themselves through repeated violent head trauma.
Of course, if a person actually manages to
fit their head inside SCP-323, then that is
a different story entirely. In these instances,
the individual becomes classified as an instance
of SCP-323-1. Within ten minutes of wearing the
skull, this person will suffer dramatic changes to
their body. Any and all body fat will be rapidly
shed as their hair also begins to fall out,
leaving them looking starved and almost skeletal
in appearance. Their distal phalanges - those
are the bones at the tip of the fingers - will
elongate and rupture the skin as they become bony,
claw-like appendages. The subject will also
find that their teeth have grown abnormally
long and sharp, while their limbs will blacken
as if they were suffering frostbite symptoms.
Along with their external transformations,
SCP-323-1 will also get increased strength
and a heightened resistance to pain.
They aren’t invulnerable though,
and can still sustain damage and injuries.
SCP-323-1 will also have a dramatic change
happen to their metabolism, which will occur a
few minutes into the physical transformation. The
subject will now need an almost constant intake
of calories, which if they don’t receive, will
cause them to starve almost instantly. With the
transformation process complete, the new instance
of SCP-323-1 has finally become the Wendigo.
A terrifying monster with one goal - to feed.
The SCP-323-1 instance will seek out any human
beings it can find so that it can feed upon their
flesh. Those who have witnessed the 323-1
instance in the midst of a feeding frenzy
have described the way it violently slaughtered
any person it could find, leaving only a mess
of blood as it devoured them, their screams
mixed in with the sounds of bones crunching.
In the times that the creature cannot find a human
to nourish its monstrous appetite, it will try to
keep itself alive anyway it can. Sometimes it will
slow down its movement to try and conserve energy,
other times it will ration whatever food
is available to it, saving some of its last
meal for a leftover snack. And on occasion, the
monster will engage in autocannibalism, a form of
cannibalism that involves eating parts of itself.
Humans certainly seem to be its preferred food
source though. Even when other sources
of meat would be easier to acquire,
SCP-323-1 will zero in on human beings and do
anything it can to make a person its next meal.
When chasing down its prey, human or otherwise,
SCP-323-1 has been observed uttering phrases
either spoken in the primary language of whoever
was transformed by the skull, or in the Severn
Ojibwe, Potawatomi, and Cree languages. These are
all native languages of the numerous indigenous
cultures that shared legends of the Wendigo.
Where do the phrases come from, though? Are
they another side effect of SCP-323’s
influence, or do they originate from
the skull itself? The Foundation’s researchers
are still trying to figure that out, and at the
moment have no clues as to where they come from.
In one containment breach in 2006, during which
an instance of SCP-323-1 was able to kill and
devour twelve members of Foundation personnel,
on site surveillance recorded audio of the
creature speaking. “Hungry… so hungry” it rasped,
while dragging a body behind it. “I… must eat. So
very hungry. Always… always hungry.” After this,
the sound of a wet cracking noise was recorded,
possibly one of the victim’s bones being broken
by SCP-323-1 so it could get to the marrow inside.
The 323-1 instance does at times seem to try and
resist the influence of the wendigo skull.
Additional recordings captured the creature
saying “Must… not eat. I have to eat. So
hungry. So… lonely,” the creature then said,
followed by noises of it eating the body. “Alone.
Hungry. Should… eat. Must. Must… eat them all. I
must eat… to know… warmth. So cold! Must eat!”
It seems that even the wendigo has its own
internal struggles, perhaps showing that
there is still something left of the human
who put on the skull, and that deep down they are
fighting against their cannibalistic impulses.
But where exactly did the Foundation find SCP-323?
And is it really the skull of an actual Wendigo,
the famous creature from North American legend?
In 1997, the SCP Foundation sent a detachment
to Bittern Lake in Saskatchewan, Canada. There
had been reports of a local community murdering
individuals and leaving their bodies in the forest
to appease a dangerous creature residing nearby.
This creature, as it was later discovered, was
an instance of SCP-323-1. Someone had found the
skull and succumbed to its influence, placing
it on their head, and turning into a monster.
Ever since, the locals had been killing people
and offering up their dead bodies as sustenance,
fearful of what would happen if they didn’t after
being brought up with legends of the Wendigo.
SCP Foundation agents were able to capture the
beast, however it died of starvation while being
transported back to containment. They also
covered up the recent deaths in the area
by giving the local residents amnestics, and
creating a cover story about an unidentified
serial killer. Prior to this, James Namagoose,
a local man who was involved in the murders was
brought in for questioning. He remained oddly calm
when interviewed, but admitted he had helped move
the bodies that were being offered up as food
for SCP-323-1, or as he called it, the Wendigo.
According to James, a local story among the Cree
people told of men who had once tried to control
a Wendigo, and perhaps even tame it through
offerings of food. Whether or not James and
his fellow locals had the same intention, their
primary concern was keeping themselves safe. He
described first encountering the creature: “A
warped man walked out of the woods, killed our
friends right in front of us. Sometimes it would
stare more than it would make to kill, try to
talk to you. It whispered at me, ‘pe misto’,
‘come and eat’. It made me cold in my bones.”
As the interview continued, James claimed
he had felt like he understood this ‘warped
man’. He described feeling like the
Wendigo was encouraging him to kill,
that the creature would help him pass when
his own time came. James told the Foundation
doctor questioning him that he had heard the
creature in his mind, and had felt it watching
him almost constantly. Mr Namagoose stated that
he’d hoped, in killing people as offerings to
the Wendigo, that his own family would be spared.
Like the other locals, James Namagoose was given
amnestics to forget all about the creature and the
murders he’d played a part in committing. So far,
none of the Foundation’s staff have experienced
any similar behavioral effects to those James
described. Those who work closely with SCP-323
or have witnessed an instance of SCP-323-1,
have felt the creature communicating with
them, or urging them to kill on its behalf.
Ultimately, who’s to say if SCP-323 is the
skull of a Wendigo like those from the legends?
It certainly seems like it is, but with no
way to tell exactly how old the skull is,
perhaps it’s actually the reverse and it was
the Wendigo legend that spawned from instances
of SCP-323-1 that were first encountered by
indigenous North American cultures hundreds of
years ago. One thing is for certain, if you ever
come across a skull with tall antlers, you should
try to resist putting it on. Otherwise, you might
not be feeling like yourself for much longer.
It was the summer of 2012 in Damascus, and for
the people of Syria, it certainly seemed like
all the predictions about “The End of the
World” were coming true. The Syrian civil
war was raging between multiple rebel
groups and the dictator Bashar Al-Assad,
whose government was shelling its own people,
as well as using chemical weapons and brutal
campaigns of violence across the country in hopes
of quelling the rebellion. Little did they know,
amidst all this pain and bloodshed,
something even more dangerous was brewing.
An anomalous phenomenon in the sunny plains
North of Damascus that may pose a threat to
all of humanity someday. A threat known to the
SCP Foundation as SCP-3989… The Bone Orchard.
This temporal and spatial anomaly was discovered
a few years earlier in 2009, before the Syrian
civil war even officially began. It’s strange
for a highly dangerous Keter Class anomaly
to be discovered under such seemingly mundane
circumstances. The SCP Foundation first became
aware of SCP-3989 after a small olive orchard
owner sold a strangely high amount of olives
that shouldn’t have been possible when compared to
his reported number of Olea europaea olive trees.
Field Agents were dispatched to question
the owner about his sudden success,
but he was resistant to questioning.
The Agents began a covert surveillance
operation to figure what was actually going
on here, at which point they discovered a
considerable spatial anomaly. The Olive
Orchard was far bigger on the inside.
The property was seized by the Foundation for
containment. The owner had no real knowledge
of the spatial anomaly, it’s likely he just
decided not to look a gift horse in the mouth
while making money hand over fist from the
extra olives he sold. The owner was given
amnestics and a new life, as the Foundation
began to study this anomaly which was now
labeled SCP-3989. To this day, no researcher
has been able to figure out the origin of
3989’s anomalous qualities. It was first given a
Euclid-class designation, and cordoned off from
the public with a simple chain link fence while
Foundation investigations were underway on inside.
On a map, the plot of land the olive farm
should only occupy about five square acres,
but this plot contains an unseen portal to a
pocket dimension within its 12 meter active zone
which doesn’t follow the same spatial laws
that our reality does. This sub-dimension,
known as SCP-3989-A, is a hotbed of fascinating
anomalous activity. Upon the discovery of this
hot zone, the Foundation established the
nearby Area 126 as a research center and
a makeshift containment facility for any
anomalous entities captured from SCP-3989-A.
It seemed like the Foundation really
had a handle on this situation,
but they were blissfully unaware
of the true horrors lurking within
SCP-3989-A. But they’d soon find out…
in the most horrifying way possible.
Dr. Farik Ghazalie was assigned to head the
research into the anomalous zone within 3989,
and naturally, he began organizing fact-finding
expeditions into the heart of the affected area.
The first guinea pig to head into the hot zone
was former Foundation Agent Josiah Harrick,
who’d been demoted to the lowly D-Class position
of D-126-15 due to failures on a previous mission.
With a remote link to Dr. Ghazalie,
Harrick was forced to venture into
the active anomalous zone to collect footage
and samples of the flora and fauna within.
The first thing Harrick noticed on his expedition
was the strange quality of the olive trees within
the active zone. The bark was a stark white, and
the leaves a bloody red. Up close, Harrick could
see that the trunks and branches of the trees
had undergone a process known as ossification,
where the material slowly becomes bone or
bone-like tissue. Hence the anomaly’s creepy name,
The Bone Orchard. These ossified
trees became known as SCP-3989-1.
Harrick also made another discovery, all
over the trees and ground were worm-like
creatures that looked like long maggots
that the Foundation dubbed SCP-3989-1A.
Agent Harrick then noticed that something was
off about the leaves of the ossified trees.
They were beating. He looked closer
and they appeared to be heart tissue,
filled with pumping veins. Dr. Ghazalie
ordered Harrick to take a branch for testing,
and when he did, the tree began
to bleed. When he looked down,
he saw that the worm-like creatures that
covered the ground were now crawling up
his legs. Ignoring orders from Dr. Ghazalie,
Harrick fled from the active zone in terror.
As he left, Dr. Ghazalie caught something
in the corner of Harrick’s body-cam footage:
A long, white hind-limb,
disappearing behind a tree.
Back in our normal dimension, tests on the
samples Harrick collected yielded more upsetting
discoveries. Genetically, the trees were identical
to humans. The trunks were human bone, and the
leaves really were made of human heart tissue.
Fascinated and just a little bit horrified,
Dr. Ghazalie authorized further expeditions into
3989-A. This time though, Agent Harrick would
be accompanied by another D-Class, and both would
be armed with handguns and protective body armor.
As it would turn out, this expedition would
be even more horrifying than the first.
As the two D-Classes explored the
active zone to collect further samples,
they found that the worms were responsible for
the ossification of the otherwise non-anomalous
olive trees. They consumed the wood, little
by little, and deposited human bone matter
in return. Harrick and his companion also
noticed that these trees were beginning to
bear fruit. Dr. Ghazalie ordered Harrick
to collect some of this fruit for testing,
but when they attempted to remove
the fruit it burst, releasing more
worm-creatures. It seemed that the converted
trees acted as incubators for their egg sacs.
Before the duo could return with the samples
they were able to take, the creature that’d
been spotted on Harrick’s body cam during the
first mission finally appeared. It was huge,
with long, white limbs, and no facial features
except for a huge mouth. It grabbed Harrick’s
companion and literally ate the top half of his
body in a single bite, before dropping his legs
to the ground. This horrifying beast, and the
many others like it, would later be designated
as SCP-3989-2A. Harrick pulled out his side
arm and shot the creature several times. The
creature ignored the bullets though and charged
Harrick. The feed from his bodycam cut soon after.
Both men were declared killed in action,
and in recognition of his sacrifice,
Josiah Harrick was posthumously reinstated to his
old position in the Foundation. Job well done,
Agent. Dr. Ghazalie, meanwhile,
prepared for the next mission.
This time, knowing of the clear dangers present
within The Bone Orchard, Dr. Ghazalie recruited
the help of MTF Zeta-9, aka The Mole Rats. Three
members, referred to as Charlie Team, were sent
into the anomalous zone, once again remotely
directed by Dr. Ghazalie. They were equipped with
experimental ultrasound technology so that they
could scan the fruit of the trees within 3989-A
without breaking any and incurring the wrath of
3989-2A, which seemed to act as sentries for the
trees. Early on in their journey, they found the
body of Agent Harrick crucified against one of the
ossified trees, his skin covered in mysterious
symbols that were likely of a Sarkic origin.
While we don’t have time to fully explore
Sarkicism, that will require a video explanation
all of its own, all you need to know is
that it’s a dangerous religious cult that
worships flesh and disease and has close ties
to similar, dangerous anomalies like SCP - 610,
also known as the Flesh That Hates.
People familiar with that SCP will
note eerily strange similarities to some of the
things the Mole Rats were about to encounter.
As Charlie Team explored, they saw a huge number
of 3989-2As observing them with eyeless faces from
between the ossified trees. They pressed on, until
they discovered what seemed to be an entirely new
kind of tree within the Bone Orchard. SCP-3989-2
were huge trees made out of what appears to be
enlarged human spines in place of a trunk. The
smaller twigs on the tree were made from heart
and lung tissue, and the whole thing was covered
in what appeared to be human amniotic sacs.
Charlie Team attempted to use their ultrasound
scanners to discover the contents of these sacs,
but one of them exploded in the
process, releasing an entirely
new variety of monster. From the sacs
emerged the larval stage of SCP-3989-2B,
smaller humanoid monsters with no faces, no
sensory organs, two pelvises., four legs,
and an exposed spine. Suddenly, Charlie Team could
feel a horrifying Sarkic presence around them,
which one member of the team described as
being like someone grabbing her liver and
giggling in her face. As the various monsters of
the Bone Orchard began to converge on the team,
the voice of the Sarkic prophet of war and
the hunt, Orok, began sounding in their ears.
He was beckoning them to join him.
While Charlie Team fled from the active zone,
Dr. Ghazalie felt increasingly drawn
into it. He heard the voice of Orok,
and he liked what he heard. Little by little,
the workers of Area 126 were losing their minds,
manipulated by the Sarkic power of the Bone
Orchard right next to them, day after day.
They were no longer loyal to the Foundation,
they wanted to serve their new dark masters.
The fourth and final expedition was led by
Dr. Ghazalie himself. He took a band of loyal
followers, and one non-believer, on a quest into
the active zone to find an Orokian temple they
believed was hidden in the very heart of the Bone
Orchard. Once they were inside, Ghazalie and his
loyalists murdered the non-believer as a sacrifice
to their new master. They carried on until they
eventually found what they were looking for: A
giant, stone temple resembling an Aztec ziggurat,
dubbed SCP-3989-4. There, they also encountered
a new kind of monster, dubbed SCP-3989-3.
These beasts were larger than the others,
and resembled ancient warriors. They had
insect-like exoskeletal armor, horned
heads, additional hind and forelimbs,
and integrated bladed weapons. What Dr. Ghazalie
and his companions thought would be paradise
turned out to be a kind of Hell as they were
led into the temple, where temporal and spatial
distortions broke their mind, and the multiple,
highly aggressive instances of SCP-3989- 3,
-2A, and -2B broke their bodies. The
whole thing had been a horrifying trap.
In that moment, back at Area 126, another fleshy,
horrifying tree sprouted out of the ground in the
middle of the complex. Monsters that had once
been Dr. Ghazalie and his followers emerged
from its amniotic sacs, and all hell broke
loose throughout the complex. Soon enough,
the base was crawling with monsters from the
Bone Orchard and staff who’d become brainwashed,
Sarkic cultists working in service of Orok. Humans
were gathered up to be sacrificed to the
ever-growing number of anomalous trees.
Things came to a head when the anomaly and
Area 126 was visited by an outside agent
from the Foundation working on behalf
of the Hazardous Materials Containment
Liaison. Biological Containment Specialist
Dr. Marshall Grant and his team arrived at
the site and were horrified to see the
Sarkic nightmare that had unfolded. They
quickly engaged in a firefight with the
anomalous creatures and Sarkic Devotees
who’d gained control over Area 126. A number
of Dr. Grant’s team were lost in the process,
but thankfully, they were able to eventually
regain control of the base and the anomalous area.
After this incident, SCP-3989 was upgraded to
Keter Class and given a huge upgrade in security,
including four meter high concrete
walls and a platoon sized regiment
of Mobile Task Force members
with heavy weaponry. The force
that took over the minds of those
exposed was designated SCP-3989-V
, a force so powerful that those infected
are given the choice to self-terminate… or be
contained forever. This may seem like a somewhat
happy ending to a grim tale, but one detail keeps
Dr. Grant, and everyone at the Foundation who
is forced to deal with 3989 awake at night.
According to all recent
studies into the Bone Orchard,
it isn’t contained at all. In fact,
the active zone… is getting bigger...
Disturbing things had been
happening on the fifth floor
of the Rose Heights apartment
building in Albany, New York.
Residents had reported strange noises over
the last few days. Screaming in the night,
pained muttering, soft weeping. Scratching
and scuttling in the walls. And worst of all,
what seemed like an infestation of
bugs unlike anything the unfortunate
occupants of Rose Heights had ever seen before.
They weren’t abnormal in size or shape - they
looked an awful lot like the common earwig,
around two and a half centimeters long with large,
curved pincers on the back. But the color
wasn’t right - unlike the usual dark brown,
these earwigs were a silvery, almost translucent
gray. When people spotted them crawling across
their walls or hiding in the carpet,
they seemed to shimmer in the light.
Eventually the building’s landlady,
Donna Tompkins, was called in to do
something about the infestation. She
spoke to each of the residents about
their experience - they reported the
strange noises, the mysterious bugs,
and even a funny smell they’d sometimes catch
in the hall. A smell like someone had thrown up.
And every single person that Donna
spoke to couldn’t help but remark that
the smell was particularly strong outside the
apartment of a certain resident, Bill Parham.
Stranger still was the fact that
Bill hadn’t been seen in days.
Donna knocked on his door, but
received no answer. She called
him on his cell phone and could hear
the phone ringing inside the apartment,
but it just went to voicemail. When she
checked the security footage of the lobby,
she saw that Bill hadn’t left the
building in the last few days either.
Donna called the police, worried that
Bill might be sick or even dead inside
his apartment. It was strange, given that
he was only in his thirties and didn’t
seem to have any health conditions,
but stranger things had happened.
Much stranger things were about to happen, too.
Two police officers arrived not long after.
They called through the door one more time,
and when they got no response, Donna
gave them the key to head inside.
The apartment was a wreck. All the furniture
was covered in dust. Filthy dishes were piled
high in the sink and on the draining board. The
smell of rot was thick in the air. There were
empty boxes of painkillers, all the pills popped
from their silvery foil, laying on the ground.
But worst of all were the bugs. The apartment
was crawling with them, and they were on every
surface. Those silvery gray earwigs. Neither
of the officers liked bugs, and it seemed that
the deeper they got into the apartment, the more
bugs there were. Some even seemed to be crawling
towards them - pointing their pincers at them
as though they were defending their territory.
This looked to be a textbook case of what happens
when a resident keels over and dies, but there was
just one problem. Where was the body? Bill Parham
had seemingly dropped off the face of the earth,
and now, a colony of mysterious bugs had started
squatting in his apartment in his absence.
Then came that smell again. That truly
awful smell, like bile and blood. It was
even stronger now and it seemed like
it was coming from a nearby closet.
The two officers, acting on pure
instinct, drew their weapons and
approached the closet with caution. Even
if they weren’t consciously aware of it,
they knew they were going to find something awful
inside. Something evil. Something dangerous.
When they threw open the closet door,
they couldn’t help but scream. They’d
found the nest. It was a huge, round hive,
like the biggest beehive you’ve ever seen,
melded to the lower corner of the closet.
The unnatural earwigs were crawling into,
out of, and around it. Thousands
of them. Tens of thousands of them.
And the second they registered
the presence of the two officers,
intruders into their nest, they began to swarm.
In sheer panic, both raised their
guns and opened fire into the closet,
but it didn’t do them any good. Their
bullets just pierced and splintered the hive,
causing even more enraged insects to spill
out and begin crawling over the two cops.
They fled from the apartment, screaming
in pain from the gnashing pincers of the
insects crawling all over their skin. They
never did find the corpse of Bill Parham.
But that’s because Bill Parham wasn’t
dead. At least, not until mere moments ago,
when the bullets from the cops’ guns had torn
through his bones and perforated his organs.
He died not long after, and if he could still
speak close to the end, he would have thanked
them both for the mercy. Because the monstrosity
that they’d just encountered in the closet wasn’t
just a nest of mysterious insects in Bill
Parham’s apartment. It was Bill himself.
This is the fate worse than death in store
for anyone supremely unlucky enough to fall
victim to SCP-439, better known by
the nickname for their unique nests,
The Bone Hive. And while these nasty little
critters may be small, they’re filled with enough
pure nightmare fuel to send you running into
682’s containment chamber for a little comfort.
Let’s go through the whole nightmarish process,
and tell you exactly what
happened to poor Bill Parham.
First discovered by the SCP Foundation in
mainland China, SCP-439 specimens largely
get by on the fact they’re not much to look at.
Unless you’re an entomologist, when you see a
strange insect, you probably just accept the
fact it’s a perfectly normal breed you’ve just
never encountered before. Nobody is hammering
down the doors of their local news station to
alert the press about the gray earwig they saw
crawling out of a crack in their bathroom wall.
But if Bill Parham had done just that, it
would have saved his life. The Foundation
would have immediately flagged the incident
as an SCP-439 infestation, and dispatched a
mobile task force to deal with it. Instead,
when Bill saw the earwig for the first time,
he was getting ready for work and didn’t
have the time to stop and deal with it.
He made a mental note to buy
some bug killer on the way home,
but quickly forgot. The insect didn’t forget him,
though. In fact, it thought he would be a
perfect candidate for the SCP-439 process.
The Foundation has tested extensively with
the one SCP-439 sample they’ve been able to
successfully catch and contain. In all these
tests, they found that 439 specimens rejected
hosts from any species other than humans. They’re
an extraordinarily specific parasite. It’s also
only one particular type of SCP-439 specimen that
you actually need to worry about: The Queens.
Despite their superficial similarities, SCP-439
behave nothing like non-anomalous earwigs. Normal
earwigs are not social creatures, they’re solitary
scavengers and they don’t keep nests as permanent
habitats. The same can definitely not be said
for SCP-439. They have complex social structures,
much like that of bees, ants, and termites,
with queens, scouts, workers, and warriors.
If you happen to encounter a worker or warrior,
you may get a painful pinch from their pincers
if you get too close. But if you end up
on the wrong side of one of the queens,
then you have a much, much
worse fate in store for you.
And it just so happened that the SCP-439
specimen that appeared in Bill Parham’s
bathroom that morning was visiting royalty.
This 439 queen had selected her target,
and now, it was time to move to the next
part of the process: Initial infiltration.
When Bill returned home from work, he was
delighted to find that the gray earwig was
nowhere to be seen - but that didn’t mean
it was gone. It was still there, lurking,
it just didn’t want to be seen. After all, the
real fun would happen after Bill went to bed.
Once SCP-439 detects that its potential host
has fallen into a deep sleep, it will crawl onto
the person’s body, and into their mouth, which
is exactly what it did to Bill. It feels like
little more than a tickle in your throat, and you
will have no idea that the tiny creature crawling
down your windpipe and into the soft, warm tissue
of your lungs spells your doom. Very few people
wake up during this process. But even if they
did, there’s virtually nothing they could do.
When Bill woke up, he was suffering from
mild chest pains and shortness of breath,
a symptom not uncommon in a number of
respiratory ailments. He had no idea
that the SCP-439 Queen was already inside him.
He got up and went about his day, trying to ignore
the pain as it gradually grew worse and worse,
feeling almost like something was moving
inside his chest. He spent the whole day
having to stop to let out a deep, hacking
cough, but coughing didn’t expel or change
anything. He looked and felt so terrible
that his boss let him go home early,
hoping that Bill would be able to sleep off
whatever illness he thought he had picked up.
But over the next couple days, his
condition only worsened. The pain grew
so excruciating he could barely move, and
he was popping painkillers like tic tacs,
to no effect. He started running a dangerously
high fever, his body trying in vain to fight
back against its lethal intruder. He
felt worse than he ever had in his life,
but little did poor Bill know, the most
terrible parts of the process were yet to come.
Through anomalous means, an SCP-439 infection
is able to induce Fibrodysplasia ossificans
progressiva, or FOP, in its victims, which
is typically a genetic disease that presents
itself before the victim turns ten years old. The
condition is infamous for its primary symptom:
Turning muscle and other soft tissue
into bone, slowly but surely paralyzing
the victim and putting them in a state of
unspeakable pain. This bone transformation
process is known as “Ossification”, and
Bill was about to experience it first hand.
His pain increased as his mobility decreased,
with more of his flesh becoming solid lumps of
bone underneath the skin. Soon enough, all
he knew was pain. It’d become so agonizing
that he was delirious with it, he was drunk
on pain. Even perceiving sunlight felt like
being stabbed in the eyes. That’s why,
like all the other victims of SCP-439,
he decided to conceal himself in a warm,
dark place where no light could get to him.
In Bill’s case, of course,
that place was his closet.
He was hurting so bad that all he could do was
curl up into the fetal position and weep as his
muscles turned to bone and his body began to
compact and shrink. He didn’t even look like a
human anymore - he was more like a ball, covered
in a bone shell and filled with warm organs.
That’s when the queen started
laying eggs among his organs.
It wasn’t long before there
was a new brood of around
30,000 specimens living inside Bill’s body.
He was still very much alive, but there wasn't
anything he could do about his situation.
His muscles had long since turned to bone,
and they had eaten large portions of his
brain, leaving mainly the parts needed to
keep his organs just barely functioning. After
all, the colony still needs central heating.
SCP-439 colonies have developed a perfect
parasitic relationship with the human body.
They even use the stomach inside the hive to
predigest food into a liquid slurry that’s
easier for them to consume. The only loser
in this situation is someone like Bill,
who is forced to become the new home for
the world’s most nightmarish freeloaders.
Eventually, when the colony becomes too
big, a queen departs to start a new one,
and the process repeats itself
once more. It’s enough to make
you want to sleep with your mouth
closed for the rest of your life.
Oh, and we haven’t even
told you the worst part yet.
Foundation scientists have conducted
tests on some victims of SCP-439,
and found that while the creatures
do consume large parts of the brain,
the parts they leave are capable of consciousness.
That’s right, their victims remain aware of
what’s happening to them the whole time, even
when they hardly seem human at all anymore.
What actually finally kills the victims
of SCP-439 isn’t the bodily trauma.
It’s the starvation that sets in when
the colony inevitably moves on. Did
we just hear you cough? You might
want to go get that checked out…
A woman wanders through the lonely hills in
the dead of night. Her purple sari is torn
and filthy from days of exposure to the elements;
her bare feet have been cut up and bruised by the
rough terrain she walks. But her clothes and her
feet are not the most noticeable thing about her:
This woman is pregnant, her belly swollen to
freakish proportions. It’s frankly a miracle
that she’s even able to walk in this state. She
stumbles and sways under the weight of the thing
growing inside her.
Whatever it is,
it’s too large to be any kind of ordinary baby.
But she keeps moving, muttering to herself in
a language that no human ear has heard in years.
Her eyes are glazed over, almost hypnotized. She
moves with great purpose, but her vacant facial
expression makes it appear as though she doesn’t
know exactly what that purpose is. She just needs
to keep moving further into the wilderness until
“It” happens, whatever “It” is. The one thing
that’s certain is that It isn’t anything good.
A car rumbles down a nearby dirt road. It’s
being driven by Dr. Vinay Ramachandran, a
medical practitioner from the nearby city of Surat
who occasionally drives out to more rural areas,
where the locals might not have easy access to
medical help. He spots the staggering woman and
immediately pumps the breaks of his car. She’s
clearly in need of medical attention, thank
goodness he happened to be driving by at the time!
Dr. Ramachandran grabs his medical bag from
the back seat and rushes towards the woman, who
collapses in a heap before he reaches her. That’s
when, to his utter horror, Dr. Ramachandran
notices that the woman’s belly is continuing
to swell at an unnatural rate. Even for a
woman who was heavily pregnant with triplets,
this would still be far too large.
And the rate at which she’s swelling
is akin to someone blowing up a balloon.
By the time Dr. Ramachandran reaches her,
the worst has already happened. The woman’s
belly has burst open, and crouching on her
corpse is the thing that was growing inside
her: An adult man, nude and covered in blood.
Dr. Ramachandran’s terror only increases
when he notices that the man is eating her.
Elsewhere, a riot is unfolding in the streets.
A megaphone-wielding instigator barks orders
for violence and chaos as the rioters
spread, setting fires, smashing windows,
and attacking any unfortunate civilians caught
in their way. It’s one of the worst riots that
the area has ever seen. Even the veteran riot
cops are frightened by the ferocity of it.
The cops descend and clash with the crowd of
ever-advancing rioters. They’re beaten back
with crowbars, baseball bats, knives,
and metal pipes. And behind them all,
the instigator continues spitting his venomous
words, working the crowd into an unmatchable
frenzy. They’ll need heavy reinforcements
if they want to get this riot under control.
That’s when one of the riot cops on the front
line, Sergeant Abhishek, notices something
strange: So many of the rioters seem to have
the exact same face. The face of the instigator.
Another place, another time, four men
are digging up a grave in a desolate
old graveyard. They work tirelessly, all
moving in perfect synchronicity. They’re
only interrupted when a group of heavily-armed
men crash the party and start firing on them.
But these graverobbers are prepared. All of
them draw revolvers like a gang in an old
Western and begin returning fire, causing the
men in tactical gear to seek cover behind the
nearby tombstones. While one of the graverobbers
continues to fire, the other three scatter during
the confusion. When his gun runs dry with
that telltale click, the men in tactical
gear immediately rise up and pincushion him
with shot after shot of their assault rifles.
He does the bullet dance like Tony Montana
and collapses to the ground. But when the
gunmen approach to confirm the kill, there’s a
horrifying twist of fate: Swarms of horrible red
flies start pouring out of every bullet wound,
swarming the attackers, who retreat, swatting
away these horrible little insects. But there’s so
many of them. There’s no way to stop at least some
of them from crawling into their mouths.
Here’s an interesting fact: All of these
nightmarish incidences are connected.
In the year 1969, a mysterious man was
arrested in Himatnagar, an area in the Indian
state of Gujarat. This man had been accused
of inciting civil unrest, terrorizing and
distressing the local people. He was later
extradited to an unknown location after the Indian
authorities received a request from a mysterious
organization known as - yep, you guessed it
- the SCP Foundation. Who could this man have
possibly been to attract such attention? The
authorities thought it best not to question it,
they were probably just glad to be rid
of the troublemaker once and for all.
Except they weren’t - Not by a long shot.
A few years later, in 1975, a group of four
men were discovered in a cemetery, this time in
Ahmedabad, another location in Gujarat, India, for
desecrating graves. This would be strange and
upsetting enough, but what really sent things to
the next level of weirdness was the discovery that
these four men were all the same man. each one was
not only genetically identical to one another, but
also to the man that had been extradited in 1969.
You’d be more than justified in asking,
“What the hell is going on here?
Maybe they were a group of highly rare
quintuplets, five children all born from the same
mother, who just happened to have a predilection
towards crime and antisocial behavior. Or perhaps
something stranger was afoot: The four who
appeared in the cemetery might have been clones
of the original troublemaker in Himatnagar. As
relatively simple as those explanations would be,
the truth was in fact far, far weirder than mad
science or coincidentally criminal quintuplets.
The four from the cemetery had been ambushed
by operatives of the Global Occult Coalition,
another shadowy organization fans of this
channel are likely to recognize. The Coalition,
or “GOC”, is a group that views itself as the
police of the paranormal world, using extremely
advanced technology to destroy supernatural
entities and artifacts rather than contain
them. They’ve been known to work both alongside
and against the SCP Foundation; both groups’
combined interest in four genetically identical
men in an Indian graveyard seems to suggest there
was something supernatural about their origin.
One of the men had been killed by the GOC, while
the remaining three were taken into custody by the
SCP Foundation. Gotta love the power of teamwork.
But who were these men? Where had they
come from and why did they share identical
genes to the first man from six years earlier?
Could there have been even more of them? Well,
in the years following, the Foundation
has been able to determine that, yes,
there are more of these genetically identical
individuals out there. Across the more rural
states of India, like Gujarat, Rajasthan, Himachal
Pradesh, Haryana, Punjab, Jammu, and Kashmir,
there may be over a thousand instances of the same
person. Collectively, they are known as SCP-2833.
While their outward appearances can vary somewhat,
instances of SCP-2833 all share the exact same
genetic traits as each other. Depending on the
area they are located in, these anomalous people
can speak various languages and regional dialects
including Hindi, English, Gujarati, Dogri,
Kashmiri, Punjabi, Urdu, and even an outdated,
unknown language that doesn’t correspond with
any known modern dialect or language family. Each
SCP-2833 also possesses the ability to manipulate
the organic matter of their own body. Now, we
don’t mean that these men will stretch themselves
like Mr. Fantastic, or turn into something out
of John Carpenter’s The Thing, but they are able
to use their bodies to create… well, something.
SCP-2833 instances can produce a small anomalous
parasite, known as SCP-2833-A. These are
often released through any bodily orifice
like the mouth, nose, or ears, or through any
cuts or open wounds suffered by an SCP-2833.
In other words, if you shot and killed an
SCP-2388, perhaps in a cemetery under the
orders of the Global Occult Coalition,
then these parasites would still be able
to escape through the victim’s bullet wounds.
The only way to stop this from happening is to
incinerate the body of a deceased SCP-2833,
burning them until there is nothing left.
So, what exactly are these parasites?
Well, they’re tiny invertebrates,
meaning they’re a small, cold-blooded organism
with no spine that can live on land or in water.
They closely resemble Dipterans, which are any
order of insects that contain what we know as
flies. Red in color and twenty millimeters in
length, SCP-2833-As are composed of a combination
of muscle tissue, keratin - the protein that
your hair, skin, and fingernails are made
from - and traces of ash, strangely enough.
They are also capable of flying with their
two wings and will use these to attempt to
enter the body of a suitable host. While
this can be any vertebrate creature, it
seems they have a preference for humans.
Once inside the host’s body, an SCP-2833-A
parasite will attach itself to their nervous
system. This then allows the SCP-2833 instance
that the parasite originated from to control
the body of the host, taking over their
bodily and motor functions, nervous system,
and all of their sensory organs. From here, an
SCP-2833 will then either subject the target
to vivid, inescapable hallucinations, or
manipulate the functions of their body.
The parasites also contain a miniature instance of
another SCP-2833, only about two millimeters long.
While these mini SCP-2833s are usually chemically
inactive, lying dormant and unable to move, this
changes if the parasite’s host is a human female.
In these cases, the SCP-2833-A creature will
implant the miniature SCP-2833 within the uterus
of their female host. After this, the new SCP-2833
will begin to rapidly grow, consuming any and
all organic matter that surrounds it. Once again,
the SCP-2833 that the parasite originated from is
still able to manipulate the female host’s body
and will use this control to make her leave her
home and travel away from any urban environment.
After a year, the new instance of SCP-2833
will be born in a truly horrific fashion.
Every time this happens, the female
host is unable to survive the process,
dying as a result of being used as an incubator
for the parasites. The newly formed SCP-2833
will retain all the memories of the previous
instance that released the parasite. They are
even able to speak fluently from the moment they
are born. But that isn’t the most horrific part.
What happens next is that the newborn SCP-2833
will then devour the body of the female host
that carried it. Sometimes, the host can die
before an SCP-2833 is born, with the parasite
keeping their body embalmed until the new
instance emerges. But regardless, the “mother”
of an SCP-2833 will always die during birth.
The SCP Foundation has conducted a number of
interviews with the instances of SCP-2833 that
they have captured and detained. The first,
SCP-2833-1, the man causing civil unrest in
Himatnagar, 1969, referred to himself as ‘we’,
implying that all of the SCP-2833
instances share the same consciousness,
acting as a hive mind of sorts. One of the
men from the cemetery, SCP-2833-4, elaborated
further on the nature of these anomalous beings
when asked how many other instances existed:
“We are in your cages. We are distant from the
hordes of the ignorant. We are grown like crops
and livestock. We are growing in numbers and
faith, and we will grow until the ascension of
Samādhi… Samādhi is beyond sight… the buried
will rise. To be consumed is the doorway to
rebirth. This is our cycle, waiting for Samādhi
with patience. We shall dance the Tandava and
consume the world for its rebirth.”
“Samādhi” is a word meaning a crypt,
usually the final resting place of a saint or
someone of religious significance. Additionally,
the “Tandava” is an ancient dance, that according
to legends, was performed by the Hindu god Shiva,
who was believed to be the source of all
things, the cycle of creation, preservation,
and destruction. So, these anomalous beings
and their parasites appeared to be awaiting
the discovery of an ancient burial site, where
someone or something was prophesied to rise,
consume the world, and then recreate it.
Thinking this Samādhi might pose a threat,
the Foundation probed a later instance of SCP-2833
for further information on its significance.
“If you intend to seek Samādhi,
your quest is in vain. For we are
the inheritor to Samādhi. Only we!”
SCP-2833-42 protested when asked
about the Samādhi by a Foundation
researcher, one Doctor Sanjay Sheel.
“Samādhi does not threaten.
It is we who were threatened,
exiled when the Colossi overran Samādhi. We
are the remnants, but we are never defeated.”
The instance went on. “We are of glorious
lineage, the chosen stock of Karcist Vaski.
Only the strongest and most zealous may serve
his purpose. To that end, we cut and consume
ourselves to persist and await for Samādhi.”
When asked who exactly Karcist Vaski was,
SCP-2833-42 answered “We
are. We are Karcist Vaski.”
That word, “Karcist”, has long been associated
with the religious cult of Sarkicism, another
group of interest you’re likely to be familiar
with if you’re a fan of what we do here. This
group worships flesh and disease and is seen as
an apocalyptic threat by the SCP Foundation. The
Sarkicist religion was founded thousands of
years ago by an ancient elder being known as
the Sorcerer-King of Adytum, also called Grand
Karcist Ion. The goal of Sarkicism is to bring
about a new age of flesh, elevating humanity to
the form of gods and potentially terraforming the
entire Earth using SCP-610, The Flesh that Hates.
So, who or what was Karcist Vaski? What role did
it have in the religion of Sarkicism
and how does it link to SCP-2833?
The Foundation has collected a number of documents
once belonging to a man named Sir William Henry
Sleeman. Sleeman was an administrator who worked
in India on behalf of the British East India
Company before his death in 1856. And it is in
his documents that some of the answers can be
found. According to Sir William, the poor of India
told him about a group of mystics, who were both
revered and feared among the country’s peasantry.
This group called themselves the Vātula,
and seemed to hold what Sleeman described as
“an unusual fetish towards death and decay”.
Sounds an awful lot like
the Sarkicists, doesn’t it?
Sir William heard rumors that these Vātula
worshiped Shiva, but were never seen at temples,
choosing instead to worship the Hindu
god in seclusion. Additionally, though,
each member of the Vātula, when asked, identified
themselves by the title of “Karcist Vaski.” Not
everyone feared them, however, as a group of men
would often attack them. These men were Thuggee,
organized gangs of professional robbers and
murderers that traveled India, strangling
their victims to death and robbing them blind.
Perhaps because of this, the Vātula seemed wary
to interact with any other worshippers of Shiva,
often dismissing them as pretenders to the faith.
Hoping to appease and gain an audience with
the Vātula, Sir William’s allies unleashed what
they called the Daughter of Shadows, better
known as SCP-029. This divided the Thuggee,
in the hopes that the Vātula would then
accept Sleeman as an ally. Eventually,
he achieved an audience with them and was
unable to determine whether this group was
genuinely devoted to their religious
beliefs or was just a group of madmen.
What Sir William didn’t realize, was that
under the vestige of “Karcist Vaski”,
this group was subtly spreading the
influence of Sarkicism over India.
As for SCP-2833, perhaps they are
the descendants of the Vātula group,
their lineage continuing through the passing of
those little parasites. It’s highly likely that
these Vātula were all early instances of SCP-2833,
which would explain why those captured by the SCP
Foundation claim that they are all Karcist Vaski.
A few years back in 2014, one of the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces uncovered a body that was
a genetic match to the other instances of
SCP-2833. However, this one wasn’t found in
India, but in Krasnoyarsk Krai, Russia. It
had strange growths on its muscle tissue and
bones, carrying multiple SCP-2833-A parasites
inside its internal organs. The body had even
been modified to contain an artificial uterus,
which carried an infant SCP-2833 instance.
It seems that not only have SCP-2833 found a new
way to evolve, carrying themselves in a modified
body, but they’re also beginning to spread further
than ever before. You’ve gotta hand it to
the Sarkicists - They’re certainly adaptable.
Grigori Gusakov and Anatoly Korneev,
both aged ten, tiptoed through the
deep, dark woods bordering their quaint Russian
village of Obrechennyy. The year was 1990,
a turbulent time for the people of Russia, seeing
as the Soviet Union was on the precipice of
collapse. But for these two young boys, global
geopolitics was the last thing on their minds.
They were too busy hunting for the legendary,
monstrous witch known only as Baba Yaga.
For those in our audience who grew up in Eastern
Europe, or those at least decently familiar with
Slavic Folklore and/or the John Wick film
series, mention of the name Baba Yaga likely
sends a slight chill down your spine. And if it
doesn’t, just wait. By the end of this video,
you’ll be afraid to go into the woods alone.
Not that going with others would save you,
as poor little Grigori and Anatoly
were about to find out the hard way…
They forged on through those witchy
woods. By our standards, the boys were
tough and headstrong. After all, the Russian
wilderness could be a brutal place to grow up,
and in a town like Obrechennyy, the old
ways of stoicism and perseverance were
prized over fear and caution. All except
for one particular area: The Supernatural.
Like many small villages all over the world
at every point in history, Obrechennyy
had its fair share of local superstitions.
Chief among them was the belief that the
local forest was enchanted, and that when people
wandered in among the trees, many of them would
never return. They’d fall into the gnarled
clutches of the carnivorous witch Baba Yaga,
and their bones would lay among the roots and
dead leaves until they someday crumbled into dust.
The spindly branches of the fall trees looked like
long, thin fingers crisscrossing above them. It
was starting to get dark out. The air was cold
and thick. When the two boys had first set off,
it’d been with the intention of proving their
mettle among the other local children. They
didn’t fear Baba Yaga; the old witch
in the woods was just another fairy
story meant to frighten children,
and they weren’t children anymore.
Though they would never live to be men.
It wasn’t long before they were beyond
the point of no return. Which way was out,
and which way was further in? It hardly
mattered anymore, as carrion birds cawed
far above. The bravado that put them here
was starting to falter now, but neither
dared show it. They’d rather be put in mortal
peril than show fear in front of one another.
Was something moving in the distant
shadows? A thin, twisted, human figure,
impossible to make out save for the faint
glow of its eyes in the gathering dark? They
couldn’t tell what was real and what was
their mind playing cruel tricks on them.
A hoarse whisper issued through the brittle
trees in the moments that followed. It was
an ancient voice, a voice that had echoed in the
nightmares of generations, a voice that had seen
centuries. It spoke in an older Russian dialect
than either of the young boys could understand,
but somehow, the essence of its message
still rung clear in their hearts and minds.
“Welcome, little children, to my forest.
Here, your lives are forfeit. You are
my property. I look forward to chewing
the tender meat off your young bones.”
That was all they needed to hear to start
running. Gregori and Anatoly turned and fled,
screaming for help, into the darkness
of the forest. Both gasped as they
ran through what seemed to be a giant
spider web. They spat and spluttered,
trying to swat away the silky
strands as they ran from the voice.
Little did they know, what they’d
just run through was no spider web.
They tried to press on, but their footsteps
slowed. The forest was changing around them.
Twisting, shifting, sparkling. What had seemed
terrifying before was suddenly oddly...beautiful.
The two boys just stood and watched as the forest
turned into a gorgeous Technicolor light show,
unlike anything they’d ever seen before. Strange
figures hopped and danced through the foliage.
One tall figure approached them out of the trees.
A beautiful, fair-haired maiden. The two boys
were entranced by her. Their hearts were filled
with pure golden light. Why were they running
before? They couldn’t even remember. They just
smiled as the woman approached them in her long,
flowing dress, smiling back. She was
like something out of a fairy tale.
They didn’t react. They didn’t
even realize what was happening,
as the jaws of the horrible, ancient old crone
closed around their skulls for the last time.
Grigori and Anatoly were never seen again. Just
another two children gone missing in the woods,
the latest entries on a long list
of tragedies to hit the village of
Obrechennyy. But they were also the
straws that broke the camel’s back.
The villagers were sick of living in fear under
the fabled witch. They would have their revenge.
The men of the village gathered up their
weapons and formed a hunting party. Guns,
torches, knives, axes, and fury. They
would slay the beast that had taken so
many of their friends and their children in the
woods. As soon as their forces were assembled,
they charged into the forest, looking for blood.
With their numerical advantage and single-minded
determination, it didn’t take them long to find
the monster in the woods. She was every bit as
hideous and nightmarish as they’d anticipated:
A gnarled, snarling crone, with long, clawed
fingers and dirty fangs. They got her in their
sights and prepared to open fire, but none of
them were ready for Baba Yaga’s counteroffensive.
She moved like a leaf in a strong wind,
swift and effortless. The men who’d made
the mistake of getting too close to her with
knives and axes tasted her terrible wrath.
She tore through them with claws like iron.
Sank her fangs into their flesh. Lifted and
tossed them like rag dolls. How could
she be so fast and so strong? The men
were terrified. This was no mere woman. It was a
true monster, squeezed into a barely human form.
By the time the creature was finally
incapacitated, it’d taken countless
bullets and strikes. How any creature could
survive such an assault was unimaginable.
Several members of the hunting party were dead
by this point. Others had been overtaken by a
strange form of madness. A couple of them had
been given to constant giggling fits or were
speaking long strings of nonsense. Others had been
rendered entirely catatonic by the experience.
It was clear that the witch had
powers beyond their understanding.
They needed to return it to the village
and destroy it as quickly as possible.
The monster was bound and dragged
back to Obrechennyy. After seeing
how it bewitched some of the men,
they avoided direct contact whenever
possible. They would do everything
they could to see justice done.
Of course, there would be no due process for
Baba Yaga. The violence that had erupted in
the forest was more than enough proof
to justify the beast’s immediate death
sentence. The local priest gave a prayer
- though he remarked that he was sure this
monster was the creation and servant of
the devil - and the execution commenced.
A local used a blessed sword, anointed
with holy water, to hack off the Baba
Yaga’s head. Its body was shot several times
for good measure, and it was finally doused in
gasoline and set on fire. The remains were
buried just outside the village limits,
hoping that the Baba Yaga’s evil wouldn’t
continue to haunt their town, even in death.
Isolated villages in the Russian steppe aren’t
famous for their communication with outsiders,
especially back in 1990, when the Soviet
Union was still clinging on to control and
the internet was still in its infancy. It
took a few weeks for the news of a village
capturing its so-called local witch to
reach the SCP Foundation. After closely
studying the peculiar disappearance records
in the area, they sent over a detachment of
field agents to investigate, and perhaps
conduct a few interviews with the locals.
They had no way of knowing there wouldn’t
be any left by the time they arrived.
When the field agents reached Obrechennyy,
it was already a ghost town. Not a single
survivor was found, only the evidence of fresh
carnage. Desiccated bodies were found in some
of the village’s houses. In others, only body
parts. A hole in the ground next to the village
seemed to show evidence of some subterranean
creature clawing its way back up to the top.
Whatever this creature was, it’d clearly crawled
back up from the earth and exacted bloody revenge
against those who had buried it. Blood trails
from some of the bodies leading back into the
woods made it clear where the creature had fled
to after massacring the entire village. Given
the sudden increase in the situation’s
severity, Mobile Task Force Epsilon-6,
aka The Village Idiots, were brought
in to apprehend the fugitive witch.
But much like the literal village
idiots that’d come before them,
this MTF had no idea what they were up against.
They entered the forest outside Obrechennyy with
superior tactics and weaponry to the villagers,
with orders to contain the creature
at all costs. They didn’t exactly know
what they were searching for in the
dark amongst the trees, but when the
first operatives laid eyes on the twisted
old crone, they almost reflexively relaxed
their guard. For some of the Village Idiots,
this would be the last mistake they ever made.
Some of the operatives began to feel
funny. Much like Grigori, Anatoly,
and some members of the hunting party,
they began to see the forest warping
and shifting around them. They giggled
at all the funny colors, and sighed,
feeling an overwhelming sense of calmness and
euphoria. It was honestly the best they’d felt
in years. Perhaps they were wrong about
hunting the witch in here. Maybe the real
anomaly here was a Russian forest that made
you feel awesome when you stepped inside.
While the affected agents were giggling
away in their own little la la land,
Baba Yaga was bringing the pain. With the same
freakish speed, strength, and ferocity that had
surprised the hunting party weeks earlier,
the witch was tearing through MTF Epsilon-6,
ripping through hardened tactical armor with her
long claws and teeth. She took shot after shot,
enough tranquilizer to put down an
elephant, but she kept fighting.
In the end, the training and numerical
superiority of the task force won out.
They were able to secure and contain the
Baba Yaga, soon redesignated SCP-352,
and take it to a nearby Foundation containment
site for further studies. There they officially
recorded all the details: From the creature’s
incredible speed and strength to its regenerative
ability so extensive that it could even
survive being decapitated and burned.
But what about the hallucinogenic effects?
Like a hungry spider, the Baba Yaga’s true
power comes in her ability to spin a deadly
web. Her body is able to produce long, thin,
hair-like fibers, each one coated in powerful
hallucinogenic enzymes that induce a sense
of placid, euphoric stillness in its victims.
When it isn’t engaging multiple targets, the
creature can sometimes take multiple days to
consume a single, still-living victim, taking
them apart and eating them piece by piece.
Speaking of eating: As you can probably imagine,
in order to keep SCP-352 uneventfully contained,
it’s ideal to make sure it isn’t hangry.
In order to keep 352 well-fed, they need to
stock up on its favorite food, human flesh. Though
specifically, 352 has a real hankering for babies.
While the Foundation are currently exploring
anomalous means of keeping the Baba Yaga fed,
until those means are fully ironed out,
they need to keep this monster fed the
old-fashioned way - only ever withdrawing food as
punishment if it attempts to breach containment.
After all, there’s a very good reason why
parents and children across the Slavic world
fear Baba Yaga. She’s always hungry, and in
the end, she always gets what she wants...
Who doesn’t love their pets, right? Whether
it’s a dog, a cat, a goldfish, or a hamster,
any pet owner will tell you that their furry
friend is so much more than just an animal
that they adopted. To many, pets become permanent
additions to the family; while they might not look
like a human being, or even have the ability
to speak the way we do, a lot of owners view
their pets as people in their own right. Of
course, a person can’t be a pet, at least a
human person can’t, right? Well, not unless
you happen to be part of SCP-1897, otherwise
known as the Human Domestication Society.
If you’ve ever been brave enough to travel
alone to the rural parts of southwestern states
like Arizona, New Mexico, Texas, Oklahoma, Utah,
or Nevada, then it’s likely you would’ve been
an ideal victim for SCP-1897. This designation
doesn’t refer to one single creature or entity,
but rather a group of similar beings. Witness
testimonies and photographs of SCP-1897 depict
them as humanoid creatures, standing approximately
five meters in height. These beings have displayed
speed and strength far beyond that of any human,
they are capable of traveling roughly
two hundred meters in only nine seconds,
and lifting weights of up to five
hundred kilos with a single hand.
These entities are not immortal and can be harmed
by conventional means, but that doesn’t mean it’s
an easy task. Any SCP-1897 instance that is killed
or incapacitated immediately vanishes, resulting
in them dropping anything that they may have been
carrying at the time. And surprisingly, these are
not mindless monsters, and actually appear to be
capable of communication. Furthermore, they do not
seem to speak a unique or distinct language but
instead communicate in standard American English,
with accents and vernacular appropriate
to the regions they appear in. However,
they will actively refuse to reply to any human
that attempts to engage them in conversation.
Now, these creatures don’t spend every waking hour
of the day roaming around the states of Texas,
Oklahoma, and all the others we listed. If they
did, it’s likely a lot more civilians would have
spotted them by now, and would probably live their
lives in fear of these gigantic five-meter-tall
humanoids. But instances of SCP-1897 will only
manifest if certain specific criteria are met,
and these are as follows. To encounter SCP-1897,
a person must be alone, or part of a group of
no more than two. If more than one other person
is with them, then no manifestation will occur.
There is one exception to the rule: If a
child under the age of twelve is present.
Secondly, neither the person nor anyone with them
can be carrying any kind of weapon - that means
no knives, no guns, not even pepper spray.
Third and finally, they must be at least
twenty-five meters from a major population center.
And what happens when all of these conditions are
met and one of these creatures appears? Anyone
witnessing their arrival will notice the creatures
materializing, appearing to emerge from some
form of unseen vehicle. When they manifest,
the SCP-1897 entities are almost always
carrying long poles with large nets at the end,
as well as steel cages, and are often seen
wearing dark green uniforms. In most cases,
they will attempt to capture any nearby person,
in a way that causes them the least possible
harm. Should an SCP-1897 creature successfully
apprehend a person and place them in a cage,
both them and their captive will vanish in a
similar manner to the way the creature appeared.
All attempts to track SCP-1897 or one
of its abducted victims have failed;
there is no way to know where they are taken.
But as far as what happens to them? That,
we do have a little more insight into.
Sometimes, although it is a highly rare
occurrence, the captured human victims may
reappear around a month after their capture.
While never in the same location as where they
disappeared from, they will always be accompanied
by an SCP-1987 instance and will stay close by
the creature’s side. At this point, the abductee
is barely human anymore. They are considered an
instance of what is known as SCP-1897-1. What
signifies this sudden and drastic transformation?
For one, these victims are always found to have
been forcibly castrated or sterilized,
essentially no longer able to reproduce
the way humans naturally do. For another, these
instances of SCP-1897-1 universally display a
decreased level of cognitive and mental function.
What we mean by that is their brains do not
function the way they should anymore.
Instead, these abductees exhibit the
same level of intelligence and capability
as the average Canis lupus familiaris,
otherwise known as the common domestic dog.
Should someone attempt to rescue a person
that has become an instance of SCP-1897-1, or
display hostility towards the SCP-1897 creature
that accompanies them, they will be met with
outward, animalistic aggression from the victim.
It has been discovered by the SCP Foundation that
these behaviors can be treated with amnestics.
Unfortunately, though, the process of an abducted
person becoming an SCP-1897-1 instance seems to
be the result of an invasive medical procedure
known as a lobotomy. This typically involves
removing or disabling certain parts of the human
brain, meaning that what has been done to these
victims is permanent, and cannot be reversed.
So, who is doing all this? Why are these
creatures collecting innocent human beings only
to reduce them to little more than animals? The
answers lie in something currently referred to
as SCP-1897-2; not another creature or entity,
not an anomalous artifact or location
with strange properties, but a website
found at the address ‘www.hdsociety.gov’.
According to the information on this site,
it belongs to a group calling themselves
the Human Domestication Society. The website
features pages such as ‘Adoption’, ‘Training’,
‘Breeding Programs’, ‘Volunteering’ and more.
The fact that this is the kind of website
you might expect to be about dogs or cats
but instead focuses on the domestication of
humans is certainly enough to turn the stomach.
As we said at the start of the video, surely
a human being can’t be somebody’s pet, right?
Wrong, at least as far as the Human Domestication
Society goes. Their website contains everything
and anything one of these SCP-1897 creatures
could ever hope to learn about owning a human
as a pet. “Has your human been misbehaving? Need
to train them to use the toilet? These pages have
all the information you need to help your human
become the most well-trained human on your block!”
boasts the Training page of www.hdsociety.gov. The
remainder of the page contains links to various
articles such as ‘Obedience Training’, which
claims an owner of a human can “show them who’s
boss without the need for physical violence”.
Also featured are mentions of how to toilet train
or play fetch with a human, how to introduce a
human to others due to them naturally not getting
along. Perhaps most chilling of all is one article
titled ‘Understanding What Your Human Wants’ that
warns human beings shouldn’t talk. And another,
‘Dealing with Strays’ offers tips for anyone
wanting to capture their own pets themselves.
It doesn’t seem like too much of a leap to think
that the SCP-1897 creatures have followed a
lot of advice from this particular article.
Arguably worst of all is an image featured
on the website, of a tall, menacing SCP-1897
entity, brandishing a picana electrica.
This device, for any unfamiliar with that term,
is a form of high voltage electrical cattle
prod, normally used for purposes of torture.
In the photograph in question, the creature is
wielding one of these while standing sternly
over a helpless captive human male, now an
instance of SCP-1897-1 with tears in his eyes.
Further pages found on www.hdsociety.gov recommend
solutions to certain human behaviors. For example,
like one might expect to find on other
pet care websites, some of the Human
Domestication Society’s articles pertain
to dealing with aggression, grooming,
house training, and even toilet training.
Then there’s the Adoption page, which states
“We offer a large variety of humans for
adoption every single day. While we cannot
guarantee a human you see listed on our website
will be available when you reach the shelter,
our inventory is updated every half-hour. We
cannot answer any questions about specific
humans pictured on our website over the phone or
email.” It is still unclear whether or not the
SCP-1897 creatures that have been known to appear
in the southwestern United States are sent out to
gather humans en masse to offer for adoption,
or whether these creatures are individuals
trying to obtain human pets on their own.
Of course, the worst conceivable answer is both.
The site is horrifyingly comprehensive, with links
to an annual human ownership convention - with
panels on breeding and preventing illegal
human poaching and skinning. It’s safe to
say that if ever you were unlucky enough to
read this website, it’d haunt you for life.
Naturally, the SCP Foundation has made several
attempts to contact the owners of this website.
They tried in vain to communicate through the
official channels about SCP-1897-1 adoption
as a way of peacefully negotiating that the Human
Domestication Society website be shut down as well
as its practices of capturing, lobotomizing,
breeding, and adopting humans. However,
these communication attempts were met with
silence. That is until a message was received
by The Foundation at Site 06, addressed to a
member of personnel that does not exist. No
data pertaining to the physical location of
the sender could be derived from the email,
but it was traced to the same IP address as
the Human Domestication Society’s website.
The email read as follows: “We will not listen
to your lies any longer. It was you who came
after us first. You who tore holes in
our world and tried to annihilate us.
You who took our olive branch of peace and
fashioned it into a spear. You who nearly
drove us to extinction. And now that we have the
advantage, you attempt to patronize us with your
crocodile tears. We will not be deceived again.
“But unlike you, we are not monsters. We have
much anger towards your kind, but we are willing
to forgive. But first, you must be willing to
change. Slavery and genocide are immoral, and not
even you deserve such a fate. It is our belief,
then, that this alternative is a fair compromise
between guaranteeing our safety and allowing your
kind to live. This is our mercy to you.
“Look at the humans who have gone through
our program. See how much happier they
are? Your correspondence tells us that
you have seen them. Seen how much they
love us. Why, then, do you continue to be
defiant? Someday you will thank us. Please try
to understand that this is for your own good.”
For now, there is little that the SCP Foundation
can do to prevent the Human Domestication Society
from abducting human beings to sell as pets
to other SCP-1897 creatures. Civilian access
to the hdsociety.gov website has been restricted,
so we recommend you stop typing into the search
bar of your browser to go take a peek.
Yes, we mean you! Seriously, stop that!
As for the entities that have appeared in the
rural areas of the southwestern states? All the
Foundation can do is position its agents nearby,
in the hopes that they can detain and neutralize
the SCP-1897s as they appear, with lethal force if
necessary. At present, the only procedure for any
human pets that are successfully recaptured
is to have them moved safely to containment
until a way of rehabilitating them is found. So
far, there hasn’t been any luck on that front.
“Help me! Would somebody please
help me? I’m lost and I can’t see!”
It echoed through the alley in a thin,
reedy voice that suggested brittleness
of body and spirit. Who wouldn’t hear
that cry and feel a pang of sympathy?
Are you so heartless that you’d ignore the
desperate pleas for help of a blind man,
clearly in distress? For all you know, he
might even be in danger. What if he walks
into a road and gets hit by a car? Would
you really want that on your conscience?
Questions like these were flying through
the head of the Good Samaritan when he
decided to go and investigate, when
it seemed like everyone else was just
content to pretend they didn’t hear it and
carry on with their day as normal. The Good
Samaritan was a person not unlike yourself. They
were also the kind of person we all hoped and
wished we would be in a situation such as this.
Kindness and generosity is a virtue, after all.
The problem is, there are people out there who
know this, and are willing to take advantage
of that kindness and generosity. But even
worse is the fact that there are things that
are definitely not people out there willing
to take advantage of human compassion, too.
But back to the Good Samaritan. He approached
the sound of the distressed man in the alley: He
looked old and frail, hunched over with the weight
of his years. He wore thick, dark glasses, and his
white cane was laying on the road a few feet away
from him. It was a tragic scene, but thankfully,
the Good Samaritan was here to help. He approached
the old man, calmly telling him that it was okay.
The Good Samaritan picked up
the walking cane and passed
it over to the blind old man. His face
spread into a warm smile, and he said.
“Thank you, thank you, thank you, young man.
It warms my heart to know there are still
good people like you on this earth.”
The old man told the Good Samaritan that he’d
come into town to get some fresh air and a little
exercise, at which point he’d gotten lost. When
the Good Samaritan asked whether it was safe for
him to come alone, the old man told him that
he always used to go on walks with his wife,
but ever since the accident, she didn’t
seem to want to be seen in public.
The Good Samaritan naturally felt for
the old man, who seemed as sweet as he
was feeble. He offered to escort the
old man back to his house personally,
wanting to make sure that he returned home safely.
The old man smiled and graciously accepted,
saying that his wife would probably want to thank
the kind young man for helping him in person.
Of course, the Good Samaritan was so wrapped up
in the warm glow of doing a good deed that he
never once stopped to question the strangeness
of this whole situation. He just walked along
with the old man, listening to him tell his
fanciful stories, as they left the city center
and crept further into the sleepy outskirts
of their small Kentucky town. He was just
rambling on, as old men tend to. He told the Good
Samaritan a little more about his beloved wife:
She was a kind woman whom he’d known for as
long as he could remember. His elementary school
sweetheart, then his high school girlfriend, and
not long after they graduated, his beautiful,
blushing bride. Oh yes, she’d always been
the prettiest lady, until the accident.
Curiosity was getting the better of him: The Good
Samaritan couldn’t help but ask what exactly the
“accident” he kept alluding to was, and the old
man was all too happy to give him an answer. Not
that this answer was, in any way, pleasant.
His wife had been trapped in a terrible fire
in town that gave her severe burns all over her
body. She was lucky to be alive, but the flames
took her beauty and her confidence away from
her. Since then, she’d become a real homebody,
often refusing to leave the house, and
rarely ever letting strangers see her.
The Good Samaritan’s heart ached for this
poor old couple. Why were such nice people
often forced to endure so much suffering? Did
this old man even have anyone else to talk to?
They reached his house soon enough, it was
the furthest one on the end of the street,
right next to the darkness of the woods. It looked
old and dilapidated, but it wasn’t like the old
blind man could even know that. As they were
walking up the small set of stairs to the porch,
the old man stumbled slightly, causing his
thick, dark glasses to fall to the floor.
The Good Samaritan reflexively leaned over to pick
up the glasses for the old man, and as he passed
them back, he noticed something strange. The old
man wasn’t just blind, he literally didn’t have
any eyes. Just two black, empty sockets where
his eyes should be. The Good Samaritan was just
thankful that the old man wasn’t able to see
him staring as he put the glasses back on.
The two of them entered the house. The Good
Samaritan was too busy thinking about the old
man’s empty eye sockets to even notice him
locking the door behind them, and by then,
it was already too late for him. The old man
called out into the dark expanse of the house.
“Sweetheart, I’ve got you a live one!”
Before the Good Samaritan could ask what he
actually meant by that, the old man shuffled off,
deftly navigating the halls through memory alone,
and took one of the two seats at the dining
table. He just sat there, smiling. Waiting.
That’s when the Good Samaritan heard a creaking
sound coming from above. Something moving,
up in the darkness of the second floor,
and then descending the stairs with heavy,
clomping footsteps. When his eyes came
into focus in the dark, he saw it there,
the most terrifying thing he’d ever
witnessed, coming down the stairs towards him.
It was vaguely human in its shape alone, but in
all other respects, it was a monster through and
through. This gnarled, twisted creature with
bulging eyes, dead flesh, and filthy exposed
fangs. Like it’d stepped straight out of
a nightmare and into the physical world,
where it did not belong. There looked to be a huge
hole in its lower torso, too, with no blood or
organs inside. Just an infinite blackness. The
creature’s lipless mouth twisted into a smile.
The creature said something in a voice that
the Good Samaritan couldn’t understand. It
was the Black Tongue, something ancient,
terrifying, and unknown. As the creature got
closer and closer, the Good Samaritan
turned and made a run for the door.
He tried to figure out the lock, his hands
fumbling and uncoordinated by fear. He could
hear the footsteps and the heavy breathing
of that thing getting closer behind him.
He was so close...Almost there...
That’s when a strange, black substance seemed
to encase the world around him. It separated
him from the door he was so nearly able to
breach, locking him in. He was trapped inside
what looked like a giant, black sphere
made of some unknown material or energy.
He turned to see that monster standing right
behind him, just grinning and waiting for the
inevitability of the situation to sink in. The
Good Samaritan had never been more terrified.
Something else began to shift inside the sphere.
A structure was growing out of the ground,
up and around him, like a cage within a cage. He
was trapped and huddled inside a strange conical
structure, as more figures entered the sphere
around him. They were just like the first,
this horrible horde of desiccated not-people.
All with grinning, lipless mouths. When they
closed in on him, the Good Samaritan had the
one consolation that at least it was over.
But it wasn’t. Not yet.
The blind old man waited in the kitchen
for five hours as unmentionable horrors
unfolded inside the black sphere. The Good
Samaritan was actually lucky, all in all,
because some sessions for victims inside the
sphere had lasted as long as 27 hours. He
screamed the entire time, with the sphere
finally de-manifesting just moments after
the screaming stopped. Remaining, was only
one of the creatures, but no Good Samaritan.
Just several neat piles of human
organs, arranged by organ type.
“Are you done in there, honey?” the blind old
man asked. “I’ve been getting awfully hungry.”
The creature replied, in perfect English.
“Yes, dear. I’ll fix you up some
supper before you go to bed.”
The creature picked up some of the discarded
organs and took them into the kitchen,
where it began cooking them into a stew for
the old man. He ate the stew not long after,
blissfully ignorant to its contents, and went to
sleep. Whatever organs from the Good Samaritan
weren’t used in the stew were simply thrown
into the fireplace to burn away into ashes.
Later that night, the old man would
die peacefully of a heart attack in his
sleep at age 81. He spent the latter
ten years of his life in service of
SCP-957. He’d never even had a wife, and
when the monster first invaded his home,
he wasn’t even blind. He’d simply come home
one day to find SCP-957 lurking in his home,
waiting for him. As far as the SCP Foundation is
aware, it always targets people who live alone.
The man had tried to resist, but the creature was
freakishly strong in spite of its wiry frame. It
grabbed him and forced his body into the dark,
gaping chasm of its chest. He was swallowed up
into another world on the other side of
the void, and returned four hours later,
a changed man. His eyes were gone, and he now
firmly believed that SCP-957 was his beloved,
if burn-scarred, wife of many years. He’d
do anything for her: Even heading out into
the world and feigning distress, to lure
people back into her terrible clutches.
That’s how the old man became SCP-957-1. He
wasn’t the first, and wouldn’t be the last.
With the old man now dead, SCP-957 would
de-manifest and head off in search of a new
victim, invading their home and repeating
the cycle once more somewhere else. The
somewhat happy ending is that in one of these
cases, the SCP Foundation somehow got wise to
the baiting activities of SCP-957, and
they were able to contain the creature,
giving it the Keter object class for its frequent
attempts to either get out or lure in new victims.
It’s never been actively hostile to
Foundation researchers and guards,
just a little obtuse. Despite the fact that it’s
perfectly capable of speaking fluent English,
it prefers to speak in an unknown, dead language
for somewhat mysterious reasons. Very little is
known about the origins or true nature of
SCP-957, but our one brief glimpse into its
interior life does little to comfort us. In
2008, the Foundation recorded 957 having a
conversation with an unseen individual in
its native tongue. Foundation linguistic
experts have been able to partially crack
the code on what was being said that day.
957 asked the unseen figure how much longer
it would have to stay here. The figure told
it that it would need to wait there for a
while and that its disguise was extremely
convincing. 957 complained that being “here”
was boring and tiresome, but the unseen figure
urged 957 to remain patient. It said “We have
to let them watch the few so that the many can
move freely. We will be done
with our research soon enough…”
Before we start today’s video, we need to ask you
a question: Are you alone in the room? Seriously,
are you alone? You may think that the room around
you is empty, but how can you really know that,
right? Think of the technology out there being
developed by groups like DARPA, the CIA, or even
the SCP Foundation - Secret agents in cloaking
suits could be standing around you right now,
watching your every move, without you even
knowing. You could tell someone about this,
but if you did, they’d think you’re crazy,
and nobody believes crazy people, do they?
Sometimes people’s whole worlds just collapse.
One day they’re living happy, successful lives,
with families and friends who love and care
about them. Then the next day, they’re truly
convinced that the US government is tapping
not only their phone calls and their emails,
but their thoughts. Perhaps even putting dangerous
brainwaves directly into their mind. Or they start
to believe that those loving family members
and friends seek to do them harm. Maybe they
start to believe their food is poisoned, and
stop eating, causing them to waste away from
malnutrition. Most terrifying of all, maybe
they start to see things that nobody else
could see. Monsters that defy rationality and
shake the very soul. Terrible, terrible things…
These are all, sadly, relatively common symptoms
of someone suffering from a severe case of
Schizophrenia - A mental illness with a wide range
of detrimental effects to sufferers, first and
foremost giving them an incredibly complicated
relationship with reality. There’s sadly a lot
of misconceptions in the media about people
who suffer from illnesses like Schizophrenia,
painting them as unstable individuals who present
a danger to the people around them. In reality,
people with a condition like this are three
times more likely to be the victim of a
violent crime. And they’re also more likely
to be the victim of something else, too...
Like we said earlier, sometimes people’s
worlds just collapse, and in severe cases,
they might simply drop off the
map. And nine times out of ten,
the reason for that is SCP-870:
The Maybe There Monsters.
Take the experience of Katrina Wayne.
She was an office temp in Tallahassee,
Florida, with an undiagnosed case of
mild schizophrenia. For the most part,
she was able to operate just fine at her job,
getting her work done at a satisfactory level
while also maintaining a decent social life after
hours. It came as a shock to everyone when she
began screeching horrifically in the middle of the
office. She backed herself up against the wall,
picking up nearby objects and throwing
them into the aisles at some invisible foe.
And this isn’t a metaphor: There really
was an invisible foe moving towards her,
and only she could truly see it. Seeing the
huge, scaly body of a mature alligator from
the Florida Everglades moving towards you would
be scary enough on its own, but this wasn’t any
ordinary alligator. Its long, reptilian head had
three eyes instead of two, and it moved towards
her on eight huge, articulated spider legs. It
was like something straight out of a nightmare.
Katrina was put on leave due to a
stress-induced mental breakdown and
prescribed a course of antipsychotic
medication by a psychiatrist. She
disappeared from her home without
a trace a mere two weeks later.
Or take the story of Daryl Simon. He was a
mechanic working in Michigan with a family
history of schizophrenia, though he’d never
been officially diagnosed himself. He was
working on the engine of a vintage corvette when
something strange happened: His garage began to
fill up with smoke. He considered at first that
perhaps it was some kind of engine malfunction
causing smoke to belch out of the old corvette’s
tailpipe, but then he saw something standing in
the smoke - A human figure. Daryl suddenly felt
a profound sense of dread seeping into his mind.
He grabbed a monkey wrench and began to
slowly approach the intruder standing in
the smoke. It was only when he was already
too close that he realized that the figure
wasn’t just standing in the smoke. It was
made of smoke. The second he noticed this,
the figure’s eyes opened, glowing red. Its smoky
face opened into a wide, toothy mouth and let out
an ear splitting shriek. Daryl suddenly found
himself running as the creature gave chase. He
threw his wrench at it as he ran; it breezed
through the creature’s semi-intangible form.
Daryl was found later that day, huddled in the
corner of his garage, muttering incoherently.
After seeing a mental health professional and
sharing his story, he was given a schizophrenia
diagnosis. He was given a mix of talk therapy and
medication, and seemed to be improving over time.
He would occasionally report hallucinations
of the man made of smoke, watching from the
corner of his eye, but it was dismissed as
nothing more than that: A hallucination.
A month later, he was gone.
Never to be seen again. But he
wasn’t the only one to fall victim to the anomaly.
Shirley Nicholson, a retiree whose schizophrenic
symptoms developed later in life, was having a
quiet evening in her home when she first
encountered an instance of SCP-870. She
was watching a game show on television when
she heard a strange noise coming from her
kitchen. A rustling, like someone was messing
with the food inside her fridge. Of course,
she’d always had a tendency to hear things,
which was why she wasn’t that nervous when
she got up and walked into the kitchen.
That sense of confidence didn’t last long.
When she entered her kitchen, she saw the
fridge door open, with the back half of what
looked like a giant ant emerging from it. Her
breath caught in her throat. That giant ant,
which seemed to be eating the food inside her
fridge, suddenly froze, seeming to realize that
Shirley had entered the room. When it backed
out of the fridge, Shirley couldn’t help but
scream. Instead of antennas and mandibles,
the giant ant had a grinning, human face.
As Shirley screamed, the giant ant’s human face
began to cackle with sadistic glee. Its jaw began
to stretch open, impossibly wide, exposing the
never-ending darkness within. Shirley turned
and ran as the creature skittered towards her
at a frightening speed. Adrenaline kicked in,
and Shirley ran for her life as the monster
pursued her through the house. It was only
when she ran out into the street, and was
seen by others in this bizarre outburst,
that the horrifying ant
monster seemed to disappear.
And several weeks after her
schizophrenia diagnosis,
Shirley Nicholson sadly disappeared too. Before
she vanished, she made a panicked 911 call,
where she screamed down the line
that the monster had come back. No
explanation has yet to be found, but there
are more cases to be investigated still.
Don Jones, who had a documented history with
schizophrenia, had his SCP-870 experience while
waiting for the bus out of town late one
October evening. He was checking his phone
at the bus stop when he saw a figure shuffling
towards him in the distance. He tried to ignore
it at first - Years of therapy had taught
him to try his best to ignore these strange
little anomalies. He’d been medicated for years,
and while occasionally he had minor episodes,
he’d lived with the condition for long
enough now that he’d learned how to cope.
That’s when the strange,
shuffling figure got closer.
Don looked up, just for a moment, to see the
thing coming towards him out of the dark. It
was about the size of a child, though a little
shorter because of how far the creature was
hunched over. Literally, hunched, the entity
had a rather prominent hunchback. But that
wasn’t nearly as notable as the thing’s
face: It had the head of a particularly
mangy-looking parrot, its curved beak
caked in what looked like old blood.
This was stranger than some of the
hallucinations he’d suffered in the
past. It looked more tangible, more
real, even after years of medication
and therapy. He felt nervous as the thing
approached him. On some subconscious level,
he knew the thing intended to
harm him in one way or another.
When it opened its mouth, and sunk the
bladed tip of its beak into Don’s hand,
he knew that he wasn’t dealing with any
mundane fantasy here. He screamed and ran
off into the night, the monster giving chase.
He later reported the incident to the police,
but his fears were written off when
his medical history came to light.
Everyone just assumed the man was experiencing
another episode, and that the wound in his
hand was self-inflicted. Of course, as
you’ve probably gathered by this point,
poor Don Jones would disappear
without a trace not long after.
Still, the testimonies get freakier...
A warehouse security guard, Alex Landry,
had his terrifying encounter while on the
job. He was on his nightly patrol when he
heard a strangely soft skittering noise
coming from inside the warehouse. He deployed
his flashlight and ran inside after radioing
for assistance. He was expecting maybe an
escaped animal or a young hoodlum messing
around inside. What he didn’t expect was
a face-to-face encounter with pure terror.
As his flashlight’s beam traced its
way up to the top of the warehouse,
he saw a monster crawling across the ceiling.
It was a giant, fifteen-foot-long centipede,
but instead of having normal centipede
legs, it had scores of twitching,
grasping human arms. He was found in a comatose
state by his partner, and spent the brief rest
of his life in a psychiatric facility before -
you guessed it - disappearing without a trace.
And most exhilaratingly, we come to the
tale of Mr. Holgate, which both ends a
little more hopeful for him, but paints a grim
picture of what happened to everyone else. Mr.
Holgate had encountered a spider-like
creature with a freakish number of legs,
which he soon realized only he could
see. During his periods of observation,
he’d seen the creature both devour a
ruler - as in, the measurement device,
not a king - as well as swallow a human whole
after an extended period of stalking the victim,
leaving nothing behind. Just like the SCP-870
instances had done to all their other victims.
When the monster eventually came
for Holgate, he was ready. It ran
screeching towards him on its too many legs,
and Holgate whipped out a gun and shot it.
The Foundation has prioritized the
capture or destruction of SCP-870.
It’s believed to be not a single instance,
but an entire species, living out there,
preying on humans and hiding in the space between
our perceptions. Even two schizophrenic people
looking at the same instance will report
seeing completely different entities.
The monsters are all the more dangerous
due to the fact that sufferers of severe
schizophrenia often report hallucinations
of strange monsters or entities, so their
pleas for help are often ignored by neurotypical
authorities. Neurotypical meaning those who don’t
experience any form of mental illness, personality
disorder, or developmental condition - People
who could never see SCP-870 coming until
they’re already being swallowed whole.
The lead researcher on the SCP-870 case follows up
the file on the monsters with an ominous note that
leaves little comfort for even those of us who
don’t suffer from schizophrenia. The note reads:
“I, personally, don't believe that the
schizophrenics are really seeing SCP-870 fully,
they can just see it more than us. We don't
see it because our brains aren't made to see
it. The schizophrenics, their brains are
wired up just that tiny bit differently,
and they can see it just a tiny bit more.
These things have the perfect camouflage,
and we simply are unable to see through it.”
To return to what we said at the
very beginning of this video. Look
around the room and answer our
question: Are you alone? Now,
at least you know the answer to that
question may not be as simple as it seems...